Guten Morgen Liebe. Guten Morgen Tim.
Eher zwei Wochen später ist aber auch immer noch nicht wirklich besser, ne?
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihunderteins, wir sind wieder da aus dem Koma äh teilweise erwacht.
Und wir hatten äh hatten einen schönen Abend mit euch äh was wir ganz großartig fanden.
Ja, also ich war von dem gesamten Ding ziemlich überwältigt. Ähm weil ich echt nicht gedacht hätte, dass das so.
Schön werden würde und so gut laufen würde. Also ich war echt super
glücklich mit unseren Gästen. Wir haben total gutes Feedback bekommen für die Gäste. Noch besseres Feedback übrigens für die Live-Zeichnung, ne? Also ich es war irgendwie so ähm,
Ich kam dann irgendwann von der Bühne runter und dann liefen halt so ein paar Leute auf mich zu, die mich, die ich halt auch schon vorher kannte.
Also vielleicht sagen wir nochmal kurz wenn man das Setup auch mal beschreiben, weil wir haben ja im Vorfeld immer nur.
Video veröffentlicht.
An. Ja, wir haben ein Video veröffentlicht, aber ich denke auch, das Vide.
Wir sind jetzt Youtuber.
Zieh dich warm an, Reik.
Ist nicht mein erstes Video, was ich auf YouTube veröffentlich.
Armes YouTube.
Genau, also für für die daheim gebliebenen und Leute, die dann vielleicht nicht in der Lage waren, obwohl sie wollten noch ein Ticket zu
ergattern, vielleicht nochmal kurz beschrieben, was das Setting war. Also wir hatten ja geladen, Lokbruch Netz-Politik zweihundert, die Gala
und das Ganze fand statt im ehemaligen Stummfilmkino Delfi im Weißensee, was eine Location ist, wo auch,
extrem viele Berliner halt so.
Merkwürdig geguckt haben, weil das kann hat halt noch haben noch nicht so viele Leute gesehen. Ich meine, das war eine uralte Location, aber die ist erst seit,
kürzerem eigentlich erst wieder in Betrieb und ist halt mehr so in dieser Theaterperformance Welt, also nichts, wo man jetzt sowieso mal wegen irgendeiner Party aufschlagen würde. Es gab vereinzelt Leute, die das schon mal gesehen hatten, aber die allermeisten waren so,
Das ist so dieser typische Berlin-Effekt, ne? Also gerade umso mehr man sich so von dieser Wende entfernt, wo das ja mal ganz normal war, dass irgendwie alle zwanzig Meter eine eine coole Bar, eine coole Location war. Jetzt hat man das Gefühl, es ist schon alles vorbei und immer wenn du denkst, jetzt geht gar nichts mehr,
Gehst du irgendwo rein und denkst dir nur so boah nee, was echt?
Das gibt's.
Dann auch noch in Weißensee, ja, wo wo viele dann sagen, weißen See, was wie komme ich denn da ins Bett? Von der Bahnen hin
und dann äh äh dann die also die Location ist der der absolute Irrsinn gewesen. Das ist das ist schon so wie der äh Moderator Henning an dem Abend hier auch sagte so zwei Laber-Podcasts im Stummfilmkino, den muss er erstmal bringen.
Haben wir.
Genau, so also das Ganze war halt ehemalige Stumpf im Kino und halt so von der ganz charmanten Art noch mit so einem Oberrang,
unten konnte man halt an Tischen sitzen, vorne nochmal ein paar Stuhlreihen, die Gäste hatten wir dann so auf den Sesseln platziert und wir äh waren dann halt alle auf der Bühne. Es ging halt los mit Nikolas und
Reinhard von methodisch Incorrect, die quasi die Pre-Show gemacht haben, auch äh
sehr dem Thema angemessen äh sich vor allem viel über die
konkreten Probleme des wissenschaftlichen Publizierens auslassend ein Thema, was wir auch so ein bisschen noch in der Hinterhand hatten, ob wir das auch nochmal in unsere Sendung mit aufnehmen. Insofern war ich eigentlich sehr glücklich,
dass die das äh,
gemacht haben, da gab's gar nicht so viel Absprache, überhaupt war das alles so ein bisschen aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt, diese ganze Veranstaltung, also nicht leicht, aber so eher,
weil weil große Masterpläne sich kaum machen ließen. Wir hatten doch enorme Probleme.
Mit den Gästen. Es gab viele Leute, die abgesagt haben, so die ersten Ideen und ähm ich glaube zwar nicht, dass wir am Ende mit einer zweiten Wahl äh an.
Nein, nein, wir haben nur, wir hatten am Anfang halt schlechtere Ideen. Äh ja, nee, natürlich, sowas muss ja auch reifen und äh,
es also natürlich gab es äh es gibt viele Gäste, die man in so einer Sendung haben kann, ne? Und wir haben jetzt ein wir haben jetzt äh sehr gute gehabt,
Und es hätte auch andere äh Kombinationen gegeben, die gut gewesen wären. Ähm das Interessante äh oder das Problem ist ja, dass man das so hinkriegen muss, dass das auch eine runde Sache ist und ähm,
Da ist man dann eben auch auf der Suche nach einem Konzept und da gab's eben anfangs natürlich ein paar äh Anfragen, irgendwie die dann auch äh,
Also es gab, es war erstaunlich, wie viele Leute so von der CDU dann an dem Tag doch keine Zeit hatten. Ähm die Münster muss irgendwas im Busch gewesen sein
Ähm und gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich dann bei, sage ich mal, prominenteren Sendungskästen tatsächlich das Problem gehabt, einfach zu spät anzufragen.
Ähm und ich denke aber wir haben einen, also ich war mit der Auswahl Gäste super happy. Super happy, muss ich echt sagen.
Ich auch und ähm es war dann halt ähm schon ein Blick eher in unser Umfeld.
Oder und unser erweitertes Umfeld, wenn wir mal jetzt äh Rike da auch nochmal mit reinrechnet und ähm was auch okay ist, fand ich äh eine gute Ausrichtung. Am Anfang hatten wir halt auch eher so überlegt mit,
gehen wir noch sehr viel weiter raus, ne? Und das hätte sicherlich auch nochmal eine interessante Note mit reingebracht und das ist sicherlich auch etwas, was man so für die Zukunft noch äh im Hinterkopf behalten sollte.
Danach ist mit ein bisschen mehr Vorlauf.
Ja also man hätte fast sagen können, dass es äh also wäre die Wahl am neunten November anders ausgegangen hätte man sagen können, das wäre Same Old Same Out gewesen, aber jetzt denke ich mir, war das gar nicht so verkehrt ähm,
Das auch mal so äh.
Dieses erweiterte Umfeld da auch einfach nochmal vorzustellen, weil so so so sehr es auch erweitert das Umfeld war äh umso
Mehr waren das halt auch Leute, die eben bei uns noch nicht in der Sendung waren und die da wichtige und interessante Sachen gesagt haben, aber das haben können die Leute ja selber gehört haben schon.
Ja, vielleicht noch mal dann zum Ablauf. Also es gibt ja ein Video von den beiden Teilen, also von dem Start mit äh Reinhard und äh Nikolas und dann äh unser Teil.
Und ähm ja, wir hatten halt dann vier Gästegruppen, also insgesamt fünf Personen.
Erstmal drei einzeln, dann zu zweit, ähm dass wir halt maximal zu viert auf der Bühne waren,
und haben dann eigentlich so mit jedem ungefähr so eine halbe Stunde brutto ähm gemacht.
Was ich auch vom zeitlichen Floh her ganz okay fand, also länger wäre sicherlich nicht gut gewesen, aber es war jetzt äh glaube ich auch ausreichend kurzweilig und dann auch wiederum abwechslungsreich. Meine bei solchen.
Inhaltsschwangeren Darbietung ist ja klar, dass dass die Konzentration auch nicht,
immer ausreicht, ne, dass manche Leute, je nachdem, wie viel sie auch vielleicht vorher noch geschlafen haben, mal mehr oder weniger äh vielleicht auch mal äh die Gedanken ein bisschen fliegen lassen, aber dadurch, dass man dann immer mit dem nächsten Block im Prinzip ja wieder frisch anfängt,
gibt's dann auch viele Möglichkeiten, sich dann immer wieder reinzusynchronisieren. Auch wenn ich nicht so den Eindruck hatte, dass jetzt besonders viele äh eingeschlafen sind im Publikum,
Zum Publikum muss man sagen auch toll, also super Leute, super Stimmung so äh von von Anfang an,
Also sicherlich auch der Verdienst von Reinhard und Nikolas, die einfach von Anfang an natürlich auch äh alles sehr lustig und unterhaltsam gestaltet haben,
Aber dann gab's ja dann für uns auch noch eine kleine Überraschung mit dieser coolen mit dem neuen LNP Ultras.
Ja, ich hatte also, dass die das äh war wirklich schön, also ähm es gab da eigentlich so einen, ich habe das nachher mit äh mit dem Pepo irgendwie bequatscht. Es gab so eine Situation, in der äh vor ein paar Wochen die,
ähm die methodisch inkorrekt Ultras auf Twitter irgendwie sagten, ah, lustig
LMP ist nach Band äh von Methodisch inkorrekt. So, ne? Und dann habe ich irgendwie so gesagt, oh shit, die haben Ultras, wir nicht
kann man da nicht den Pepe aus dem Ruhestand holen, denn der Pepo ist, ähm, Podcast dabei, den Podcast blauer Salon und hat eine sehr illustre ultra Vergangenheit beim FC Schalke null vier,
und äh er schrieb dann irgendwie nur so echte Ultras Pollen nicht rum, sondern machen,
war aber eigentlich relativ angepisst, weil er schon die ganze Zeit am am Vorbereiten war,
Also er war halt sehr unglücklich, dass ich, dass ich quasi auch ihn spezifisch angesprochen habe, weil er schon längere Zeit in den Vorbereitungen war.
Was du wusstest oder nicht wusst.
Nee, das hat er mir jetzt nachher erzählt. So und der hat halt ein, ein riesiges.
Banner da irgendwie ultras Lockbuchnetzpolitik ausgerollt, hatte alle Gäste, die da waren mit so ähm,
Also A drei Blättern, wo LMP zweihundert draufstand ausgestattet und als dann das Introkram äh stand, haben wir es alle hochgehalten und damit so geflattert, was ein ein sehr sehr schönes äh Bild ergab,
Und ja also der alte Capo hat da auf jeden Fall nochmal ordentlich einen gezeigt so,
Es gibt da äh Fotos äh in dem in dem Post zu äh LMP zweihundert aus Mitlike. Ähm da kann man das äh sehr schön sehen, was da äh gebaut wurde und das war echt ähm.
Das war irre und da haben wir auch nicht so wirklich äh mit gerechnet. Ich habe auch gesehen, dass der Papo da vorne an der Bühne rumgefuchtelt hat mit seinem mit irgendwie aber mir war nicht klar, äh was da äh was da tatsächlich ähm
dass er da so einen Banner haben würde. Also das war wirklich eine eine geile Sache.
Von den Ultras Logbuch Netzpolitik, das hat uns sehr überrascht und sehr gefreut.
Und dann äh na ja, muss man, also wir hatten eben diese, diese wirklich einmalige Atmosphäre in diesem ehemaligen Stummfilmkino, das äh glaube ich eine Location, weil die alle Leute sehr, sehr begeistert hat
Und ähm dann gab's ja aber auch so ein paar Überraschungen, die wir verteilt haben, die möchte ich ja auch nicht unerwähnt lassen. Und zwar hatten wir,
Er gibt auch Bilder von dem Blogpost, die LNP zweihundert Taschentücher. Ähm weil ich mir gedacht habe, ähm,
Logbuch, Netzkritik ist einfach eine traurige Sendung und da weint man und da äh gibt man den Gästen natürlich ähm.
Taschentücher und mit Branding, also schwarze Taschentücher, auf denen dann in dieser alten Schreibmaschinenschrift LMP zweihundert stand. Außerdem
gab es äh Aufkleber, so plott geschnittener Aufkleber, also das ganz feine, ganz edle Angelegenheit, die uns ähm.
Geschenkt wurden von ähm Tobias, der auch die Taschentücher für uns gemacht hat,
Ähm und wir hatten ähm Shirts im Angebot, die uns der äh Sven äh Sediviv klar gemacht hatte, beziehungsweise der hat uns das Motiv klar gemacht. Produziert hat das auch der.
Auch der Tobias Herrmann und äh so gab es äh eben einige Geschenke und einiges zu kaufen.
Und dann eben, was ich äh also quasi, man ist ja im Stumpf im Kino, muss ja auch ein bisschen Kino sein. Also brauchte man ein Augenkino und das war dann hing quasi über uns, hing eine große Leinwand.
Die bei äh Nikolas und Reinhard genutzt wurde für Folien,
aber als wir anfingen, hatten wir einen Livezeichner, nämlich den Roland Brügner, der live dazu so gemalt hat und das war eigentlich der der Gag, als ich von dieser Bühne runter kam und dann Leute halt zu mir kamen, die mich kannten und sagten, ja Lino ist toll, super Live-Zeichner,
So, ich komme von dieser Bühne runter und da irgendwie äh bin tausend Tore gestorben, bin emotional total überwältigt, freue mich über die Gäste
und diese Live-Zeichnungen haben Tim und ich ja die ganze Zeit nicht gesehen. Äh wir wussten eigentlich hatten wir so ein bisschen vergessen, dass das stattfindet.
Ihr wird zwischendurch merkte man, dass das Publikum an Stellen lachte, wo das nicht angemessen war, zumindest nach unserem Eindruck,
Roland dann oben irgendwelche Scherze gemacht und ähm also das hat die Leute sehr äh begeistert, aber den,
Knüller haben wir dann äh noch oben drauf gesetzt als ähm also quasi zum Ende der Sendung, also also als die Sendung zu Ende war.
Hatte ich einen Stapel mit äh T-Shirts in der Hand, bedruckten T-Shirts,
denen diese Live-Zeichnung waren, denn während quasi Roland oben live zeichnete, hat Tobi diese Live-Shirts, also diese Live-Zeichnungen auf T-Shirts gedruckt
um, damit wir die dann im Anschluss unseren Gästen schenken konnten und diese Augen, das war, ich habe das äh hätte nicht gedacht, dass sie es so ähm,
beeindruckt, weil die so dachten so wie jetzt Moment äh hä das wurde doch gerade live da oben gezeichnet, wieso hast du zehn Minuten später äh zum Ende der Sendung,
bedrucktes T-Shirt so und die haben dann irgendwie so äh man merkt ihm wie sie, wie die so ratterten und dachten so, hm, die haben die Live-Zeichnungen vorher angefertigt,
Aber Moment mal, das geht ja gar nicht, weil die Live-Zeichnungen waren ja quasi davon abhängig, was ich selber auf dieser Bühne gesagt habe und äh man merkte so richtig, wie die rattert ein bis.
Wir haben die Sendung natürlich vorher äh drei Wochen lang auswendig gelernt mit unseren Gästen.
Na ja, aber das war echt, also wirklich hat war wirklich geil, dann quasi wirklich ein paar Minuten später Live-Shirts von diesen Live-Zeichnungen zu haben und die natürlich als Unikate.
Äh denn da unseren Gästen zu äh zu schenken. Also da nochmal echt äh vielen vielen Dank an
Tobias, der das alles gemacht hat. Tobias Roh, Tobias Roland, sag schon. Tobias Herrmann, herzlichen Dank dafür und.
Dann haben wir.
Dann muss ich noch kurz was zu sagen, weil ähm ich finde.
Also ich war auch sehr glücklich, damit wie das äh äh gelaufen ist. Zumal ich halt auch der Meinungen das war schon auch,
Eine Art und Weise, wie man das Format Podcast auf einer Bühne wirklich gut unterstützen kann, ja? Wir haben uns ja
was die inhaltliche Gestaltung betrifft ohnehin schon etwas umgestellt, weil wir natürlich dort nicht das machen wollten und konnten und auch nicht hätten tun sollen, was wir jetzt hier in der Studie Situation machen
Ja, also es wäre vollkommen langweilig gewesen, dadurch Nachrichten durchzugehen und irgendwie stundenlang irgendwelche Fakten runterzubeten. Das ist zwar der Kern
die Kernaufgabe dieses Formats, aber das ist halt nicht die Kernaufgabe
einer Show, die ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch äh unterhaltsam und und kurzweilig sein soll, also nicht dass wir denken, dass es uns hier nie gelingt, halbwegs kurzweilig zu sein, aber äh es war halt eine ganz andere Ausrichtung. Und dann muss man natürlich auch immer noch sagen,
Wenn man jetzt Radio auf einer Bühne macht, was kann man denn halt noch mehr bieten als äh,
nur dasselbe in grün und man schaut halt dabei zu, ne? Ich bin ja auch ein großer Kritiker von so äh sinnlosen Videoformaten. Also es gibt,
Gute Anwendung für Video, ne? Aber die, die Frage mit, willst du dir nicht mal was mit äh Video machen, Tim, begleite ich halt immer nur mit, ja, nur, wenn es wirklich auch einen Mehrwert.
Und ich denke, dass dieses diese Live-Zeichnung auf mehreren Ebenen einen Mehrwert äh geboten hat. Ich meine, das äh Live-Zeichnung, man kennt ja auch Grafik Recording sagen, ist ja auch ein Konzept, was bei äh anderen Veranstaltungen auch genutzt wird. Ich finde, Rolands,
Stil ist da nochmal sehr spezifisch, nochmal sehr, also sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr speziell, also das man hier auch ganz positiv, ja? Ähm.
Weil es ein zumindest von dem, was ich bisher von anderen gesehen habe noch sich weniger so an so,
Strukturierung des Inhaltsorientiert hat, sondern es war mir so ein Wimmelbild, was dann eigentlich am Ende entstand,
Ähm auch wenn ich mir sehr gut vorstellen könnte, dass man ähnliches auch mit äh anderen Leuten machen kann, die es in diesem Grafical Recording Bereich da ganz vorne sind. Da gibt's ja so einige. Und das das unterstützt halt einfach das gut, weil man hat halt was zu schauen.
Quasi auch so eine live Reflektierung des Inhalts gerade, also da ist eben was gesagt worden und es leuchtet in gewisser Hinsicht nochmal so dreißig Sekunden nach, weil es sich eben auch grafisch manifestiert und es unterstützt halt.
Generell diese Late Back Situation, mit der man Podcasts
konsumiert und in dem Moment dann halt einfach live, sodass einfach dieses nochmal drüber nachdenken, während man was Neues vielleicht auch schon wieder aufnimmt, dass man einfach sehr reflektiert mitgeht
und ähm ja, das äh fand ich einfach äh grandios. Ich hatte ja schon mal sowas ähnliches gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das hier schon mal erwähnt hab,
Äh da gibt's leider keine Videoaufzeichnung von nur Fotos mit Raumzeit.
Wo auch die Sendung quasi live begleitet wurde grafisch, aber eben jetzt nur durch Fotoauswahl, also gab,
dieses ganze äh Esa-Archiv, was da
und NASA-Archiv, was dann konsultiert wurde und worüber wir eben auch gerade gesprochen haben, Mondlandungszackbilder von der Mondlindung. Da trägt, zack, Startregbilder und so weiter, ja? Also man hatte einfach immer gerade mal visuell genau das und es extrem wichtig
dass man solche visuellen DJs hat,
die äh sowas begleiten und an der Stelle äh finde ich wird da einfach ein rundes Ding draus und das ist halt ja auch hier äh wieder so gewesen.
Ja, wir hätten sonst halt die Leute alleine in, also wir hätten die Leute am Ende eigentlich drei Stunden am Stück in dieses stumpfe im Kino gesetzt und hätten denen nichts anderes bieten können als unsere,
sich da, ne? Und das sieht, also es sieht man ja auch ein bisschen, denke ich
Bei den anderen Livesendungen, die wir schon gemacht haben, was weiß ich, bei Congress oder Camp, äh wo es dann Videoaufzeichnungen gibt, das ist da eigentlich nichts zu sehen gibt außer Gesichter und dass das eben dass man dann am, ne, nichts gegen die,
herausragenden Leistungen des Wog,
das äh also das Video Operation Center vom CC, was es immer wieder ermöglicht, diese Videoaufnahmen zu machen und was auch dieses Mal dabei war und diese Wahnsinnsqualität geliefert hat mit zwei Kameras und allem. Aber bisher würde ich sagen, waren wir einfach nicht in der Lage.
'ne Bühnensituation zu bieten, die des Films wirklich nennenswert würdig war. Und das haben hier aber jetzt
Tobi und äh Roland eben für uns geteilt, muss dazu sagen, keine einzige dieser Ideen kam von mir
oder von uns. Das waren die beiden, die sagten oder die ich auch angesprochen habe und gesagt habe, ey, ihr macht doch sowas professionell den ganzen Tag. Wie ist denn euer Konzept hierfür? Ja und dann kam das mit
sagte Roland live zeichnen und ich muss echt sagen, ich war von all dem noch nicht mal besonders überzeugt, so dachte so, ja okay, Roland, nee, finde ich gut, du kannst es, mach mal.
Und tobe dann mit diesen Live-Shirts und ich dachte so ja,
Weißt du, ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt die Leute vom Hocker äh reist, aber die Leute standen nachher alle Schlangen und wollten die kaufen,
ähm ging aber nicht, gab's nicht zu kaufen. Ähm also das äh war wirklich auch cool so wie die beiden das geformt haben. Im Prinzip, was wir, also mit Ideen, die wir ja dann angenommen haben, aber die wirklich von denen kamen.
Ähm.
Bringt uns auch so ein bisschen zu dieser Geschichte mit den äh T-Shirts, also von den Shirts, die wir halt im Verkauf hatten, sind auch noch ein paar übrig,
Wir haben einfach auch glaube ich die die Zeit, die letztlich da vor Ort zur Verfügung steht, um um die zu kaufen ein bisschen ähm zu klein gerechnet und ähm.
Von daher sind noch ein paar über, die wollen wir jetzt noch vom Kongress äh verkaufen. Da werden wir äh uns nochmal an euch wenden. Es wird irgendeine Form von Online-Verkauf geben.
Genau, wir kümmern, also wir eroieren gerade, wie man das am elegantesten macht, so. Wir wollen jetzt nicht irgendwie unter die Online-Shopper gehen und jeden Tag zwei Pakete rausschicken. Also wir werden wahrscheinlich einfach den Bestand an Shirts, den wir noch haben.
Raus und dann gucken wir weiter.
Und dann versenden und dann ist gut.
Genau.
Hörer waren, also Gespräche mit hören, wollte ich noch ganz kurz sagen. Das war also wirklich auch äh also echt irre, ähm.
Mal, also ich hatte das ja auch in der Sendung schon gesagt, ich war ja skeptisch, dass da überhaupt so viele Leute zusammen äh zusammenkriegen würden, die dahin kommen. Ähm.
Echt nicht.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist äh der Unterschied. Ähm wir haben wirklich äh tolle.
Gespräche mit mit vielen Hörern geführt und hören, also höre, Hörer und Hörern und Hörerinnen, die dann einfach mal so kurz anquatschen, das ist ja auch immer eine etwas,
Komische Situation für uns, weil wir dann mit Leuten reden, die uns wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr gut kennen, wir sie aber zum ersten Mal sehen, also bitte verzeiht, wenn ich da vielleicht teilweise ähm.
Komisch war in den Gesprächen oder nicht, wo wirklich wusste, was ich sagen soll, aber ich fand das äh super nett aus zu sehen, dass es tatsächlich auf, dass wir wirklich,
coole Hörer haben, ja? Hätte ja auch sein können, dass das nicht so ist. Und ähm das war wirklich eine eine feine Sache.
Ich hatte, ich hatte dann die Zweifel, aber ich hab.
Nein, ich wollte jetzt nicht, aber du weißt, was ich meine. Das ist einfach schön, da mal die Gesichter zu sehen.
Ja, ich weiß was, ich weiß genau, was du meinst und ich habe da eigentlich auch nur den, den Vorteil, dass ich halt einfach schon diese diese ganzen Hörertreffen in den letzten Jahren gemacht habe und von daher die Situation auch äh ja kennengelernt.
Der Hörertreffen mache ja auch nicht, weil ich Angst habe, am Ende alleine in irgendeiner Kneipe zu sitzen.
Das wird bestimmt passieren hier.
Ja und dann äh dann kam der,
Und dann war äh super nett, also viel einige haben echt dann so spontane und auch vorbereitete Geschenke gemacht, was ich echt total cool fand so. Äh was mich auch sehr gefreut hat und.
Die Gäste.
Ja ja wo dann wo man dann wo auch ich da sagen muss, das war denn auf offene Weise so perplex, dass ich da vielleicht auch im Nachhinein irgendwie auch vielleicht gar nicht wusste, wie ich reagiert habe oder reagieren soll.
Aus dem NS.
Die waren geil, aber auch irgendwie hier, ne, die selbstgebastelten Luftballonfiguren oder so, ne. Ähm,
Mit dem Hinweis, du, wenn wenn die nicht wegwerfen und wenn dann vorher nochmal genauer reingucken, bin ich mal sehr gespannt, was sich da noch ergibt. Ähm also das war alles,
insgesamt einem eine Sache, die mich ein bisschen einfach über also geplättet hat, war wusste ich auf vieles nicht mehr wirklich so einzuordnen oder zu reagieren, fand ich irre.
Ähm was ich hatte eine Sache noch. Ach so, genau. Wir müssen ja auch noch sagen, wir hatten ja diese Logenplätze, ne? Das müssen wir auch erwähnen. In die Logenplätze, das waren ja die Premium äh Gäste, die haben äh die haben ja die werden ja viel zu billig, die Logenplätze, ne.
Ja, deutlich.
Die waren deshalb, also dass sie zu billig waren, erkennt man ja daran, dass sie als allererstes weg waren. Und wir wollten die preislich eigentlich natürlich so koordinieren, so einordnen, dass die,
dass die wirklich nur so für die
für den für die obersten ein Prozent der Leute sind. Ähm, in der Loge gab es dann natürlich Sektempfang.
Und so ein bisschen.
Bisschen äh Snacks und so, oder? Bisschen Oliven, bisschen Käse, bisschen Erdnüsse und so. Äh wurden da gereicht und äh da waren halt äh das war glaube ich auch äh ganz schön. Also es hat auf jeden Fall alles irgendwie
äh Spaß gemacht und ich habe jetzt schon Sorge, ob wir das jemals äh toppen können.
Leider müssen wir auch sagen, wenn wir das jemals toppen wollen oder überhaupt nochmal machen sollen,
werden würdet, wahrscheinlich nicht zu dem Preis wieder anbieten können,
Das ist äh das ist aber unser Fehler, nicht eurer. Wollen wir jetzt den Gästen hier kein schlechtes Gewissen machen, die dahin gekommen sind? Wir haben tatsächlich,
unterschätzt, wie viel Aufwand das ist in in Vorbereitung. Ähm wir haben Unmengen an Dingen da an quasi,
integralen Bestandteilen da mehr oder weniger
ohne gegen, also ohne Bezahlung äh bekommen, ne? Also das Videostream vom Walk. Äh die Leute, die uns beim Einlass geholfen haben, ähm was ich hier erzählt habe, äh Roland und Tobi Livezeichner und und und die die.
Schenke, die wir da verteilt haben, die Shirts.
Wahl freiwilliges Engagement.
Alles freiwilliges Engagement und äh dennoch sind wir jetzt mit dann Reisekosten, die sich dann doch höher gestalten, als man so auf Animain für die Gäste. Ähm so ausgekommen, dass sich die Veranstaltung,
Lasst uns die Veranstaltung nicht ins Minus gerissen hat. Aber gemessen an dem Aufwand, den wir trotz aller dieser freiwilligen Helfer noch selber hatten und.
Obwohl wir diese ganzen freiwilligen Helfer noch nicht mal bezahlt haben.
Ähm war das am Ende ein Null-Summen-Spiel und das äh ist echt äh erstaunlich, weil die Preise waren und,
Feedbacks stimmt auch. Die waren natürlich knackig. Also ne, mit dreiundzwanzig Euro Einstiegspreis äh äh klar für das, was wir am Ende geboten haben, glaube ich
haben wir dann einen fairen Kurs gemacht.
Ja, ich meine, es war halt immerhin irgendwie drei Stunden Programm und.
Muss ja trotzdem erstmal irgendwie wir haben nicht zu wenig geboten, aber ich ich hätte.
Gehofft, dass wir bei dem Preis irgendwie auch eine was weiß ich, eine eine Summe an Geld zustande bekommen, die wo wir am Ende eben was bei verdienen, ja? Weil wir ja auch dann gesagt haben, wer äh Loge bucht oder wer,
den äh Unterstützerpreis zeigt, der unterstützt Lokbuchnetzpolitik,
Über diese Veranstaltung hinaus und das ist eben nicht der nicht der Fall gewesen, war aber ehrlich gesagt auch nie mein Ziel. Nur wenn man dann mal guckt so.
Man schlackert halt mit den Ohren, was so ein Spaß kostet. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, obwohl wir ja unsere Kalkulationen hatten. Aber was dann da irgendwie noch so an Scherzen mit reinkommt, hier mal eine Veranstalter, Haftpflicht, da mal noch eine Zugfahrt. Ähm.
Ja und vor allem haben wir auch ähm ich habe ja irgendwie eine halbe Meterebene dahin gefahren, die ganzen äh Kabellagen und.
Transporter Mieten und der ganze Killerfit, also Theoret.
Wie gesagt, wollen wir euch gar kein schlechtes Gewissen machen, weil wir eher erstaunt, was der ganze Cinoba kostet und wenn wir jetzt alles, was da gewesen ist, hätten bezahlen müssen. Ne, also wenn man jetzt mal überlegt, so wird's die.
Personal, Merch, äh Transporter, der Videocrew. Ich, also ich glaube, wir wären beim, wir werden die Stühle, äh, wir werden beim beim beim Ticketpreis von sicherlich im Bereich sechzig, siebzig Euro gewesen.
Also einfach für das, was wir, was, wenn wir jetzt faire Preise gezahlt hätten und nicht einfach unsere Freunde ausgenutzt hätten. Äh so.
Genau, da wollen wir aber auch nicht ankommen. Also wir müssen uns das mal alles äh äh überlegen, wie man das das nächste Mal, wenn's ein nächstes Mal gibt, das zusammen äh gefegt bekommt. Aber
Macht auf jeden Fall schon Lust auf mehr, diese ganze Live Podcast-Sache ist ja auch etwas, was wir schon sehr lange vor uns hergetrieben haben und jetzt durch diese äh lustige Konstellation Mitte zweihundert und in fünf Jahren dann einfach mal beschlossen haben, jetzt machen wir das und ich glaube, das war auch,
gut, weil ne? Man muss halt meine mir war vielleicht noch mehr als dir schon klar,
in etwa, was das alles so mit sich bringt, ne? Und ähm bin da immer so ein bisschen zurückhaltend, denke mir immer so
Ja, ich muss in der bestmöglichen Verfassung sein, mental und zeitlich damit ich dann auch da bin, dass ich dann auch
den Zugriff habe auf alles und das war teilweise äh etwas schwierig, weil ich ja noch die noch vorher hatte und so weiter. Du warst viel unterwegs. Na ja, also,
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, tolle Veranstaltung, vielen Dank für alle, die gekommen sind, vielen Dank für alle, die äh zugeschaut haben, noch zuschauen werden und ähm.
Vielen Dank an alle, die uns da so enorm unterstützt haben mit allerlei äh mit allerlei Aufgaben, ne? Also das geht los mit mal jedem Einlass machen, mal eben Shirt-Verkauf machen, mal eben ab ab ein Uhr da sein, für auf
das sind alles so viele Dinge bei denen wir da unterstützt wurden von so vielen Leuten, dass da ist mir echt die Spucke weggeblieben und dafür möchte ich allen nochmal recht herzlich danken.
So, jetzt an halbe Stunde hier, die Leute wollen was über das Schlechte in der Welt hören und wir äh klopfen uns hier nur selber auf die Schulter. Reicht jetzt.
Na ja, wir müssen das jetzt auch erstmal mental wieder runterfahren langsam äh.
Muss man, aber das muss man echt irgendwie erstmal verarbeiten, so was wirklich, das war ein ganz tolles Erlebnis.
Aber gab's noch irgendwas nicht? Es gab kein Spiel. Mhm.
Es gab kein Spiel und deswegen hat sich für uns auch kein äh Quest ergeben.
Und genau deshalb suchen wir jetzt fünfunddreißig gelbe Puzzleteile, äh die wir gerne wieder zusammensetzen würden, um die Nachricht zu entschlüsseln.
Das wäre ganz gut.
Meldet euch nicht bei uns.
Ja. So, äh also wirklich. Ne, meldet euch bei uns bitte.
Ihr kennt ja das Fasswort nicht. Ähm kommen wir zu den,
So nach LMP, ja, man ist so gerade noch in so einem Taumel aus aus Emotionen und und denkt immer so, boah geil so es besteht Hoffnung, ja? Insbesondere äh Daniel, also eigentlich alle unsere Gäste, die da waren, haben ja Hoffnung gemacht,
so irgendwie nicht ganz so dramatisch auf die Zukunft zu blicken. Und das musste natürlich bestraft werden.
Dachte sich der Armi und wählte Donald ich kann das immer noch nicht sagen.
Also dieser.
Dass Trump das Trumpeltier äh regiert die Welt. Schöner, schöner Till für ein Kinderbuch übrigens.
Ähm ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Es war jetzt irgendwie schon auch das zweite Mal dieses Jahr, dass ich irgendwie so morgens geweckt wurde und so äh übrigens Shit the Shit Hess, Hit the Fan äh ins Gesicht gesagt bekam und mein Bedarf war eigentlich schon gedeckt.
Und ähm sicherlich.
Hat jeder so gespürt so, oh Gott, es könnte passieren, aber man hat ja inständig so gehofft, so wird schon, wird schon wieder.
Wird schon weggehen.
Also es ist ein Mensch, der dessen Kernwahlkampfversprechen ist, war irgendwie eine Mauer zu bauen zum Nachbarland, der.
Allen Ebenen.
Den ich eigentlich also der ein absoluter,
Also der halt wirklich psychisch, nicht gesund ist. Und das siehst du in allem, wie er, wie er handelt und was er sagt und was er tut, ist ganz offenkundig, dass dieser Mensch.
Persönlichkeitsstörungen hat.
'ne Persönlichkeitsstörung hat. Und ähm ich war schon davon ausgegangen, dass eine Demokratie
irgendwie dagegen Abwehrmechanismen hat, ja, dass so ein, dass halt so ein Vollspinner Präsident wird
Und ich habe das aber auch immer befürchtet, dass das passieren würde, also ich habe immer mit dem Gedanken gesponnen, aber gleichzeitig habe ich mich auch echt bei gerade bei diesen Debatten,
bei diesem Präsident Chill die Base.
Hat er mir schon fast wieder leid, ne? Also ich bin ja Psychologe, ich weiß ja, was auch was für ein Leid mit Persönlichkeitssteuerung einherge,
Zumindest theoretisch. Äh praktisch habe ich ja nie jetzt irgendwie,
viele in dem Bereich therapeutisch gemacht, aber der der tat mir leid, ja? Also die Entgleisungen irgendwie äh Sachen, die Woman oder sowas zu sagen in einer
in diesem Kontext, ich habe gedacht, also es ist mit dem Mann, es ist vorbei und und er merkt es nicht.
Weil es für mich unvorstellbar war, dass es dass.
Der in der Lage wäre eine Mehrheit hinter sich zu vereinen. Dass der natürlich an einem radikalen Rand gefischt hat, der äh einfach vielversprechend ist.
Und dass der eine ganze Menge Mauern durchbrochen hat, die irgendwie noch so ein bisschen was mit,
Ja, mit diesen sie zu tun hatten, mit Anstand, dass man eben nun mal,
kein Rassist ist, ja, dass man irgendwie Fortschritt und Entwicklung wie so eine Gesellschaft über über hunderte von Jahren gemacht hat, nicht einfach über Bord wirft, nur weil man mit dem Status quo nicht zufrieden ist, ja? Und das.
Dass da Menschen natürlich eine Vergangenheit zurück wollten, die sie damals schon nicht hatten, ja? Und einen Wandel rückgängig machen wollen, für den der Präsident als allerletztes verantwortlich wäre.
Und unter dem sie halt leiden und denen sie auch nicht zurückgängig machen können,
wovor es mir wirklich grau ist, ist die äh die Enttäuschung, die diese Person haben werden
Eins, zwei, drei, vier Jahren. Und alles, was ein ein Faschist dann noch machen kann, ist lauter zu schreien,
Und ich bin gespannt, ob es Donald Trump gelingen wird, äh noch mehr Schuldige zu finden an den Dingen, die er selber auch nicht ändern kann
wenn irgendwann mal diese Mauer gebaut ist und die Menschen abgeschoben wurden und so, werden die Leute sehen, dass es ihnen immer noch nicht besser,
Und wirklich besser gehen wird, schauen wir uns das an, irgendwie Deutschland hat die Geschichte gerade vor
sechzig Jahren durch. Richtig besser geht's dir erst wieder, wenn du die Welt in Schutt und Asche gelegt hast, dein eigenes Land auch und die Wirtschaft dann floriert, weil es eine ganze Menge wieder aufzubauen gibt, die kaputt gemacht wurde. Und ähm.
Ich bin schockiert, dass das geschehen ist
Ich bin in Sorge, das sind wir alle und vor allem wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, wie dann so äh ne, die die Rechtsradikalen Großbritanniens, die rechtsradikalen Deutschlands, die Rechtsradikalen Frankreichs, die Rechtsradikalen Ungarns sagen
top. So, jetzt geht's rund.
Polen. Russland.
Und dann diese ganzen äh diese wirklich Verarschungsmedien,
allen voran Bright Breitbart äh sagen. Ja wunderbar. Wir expandieren jetzt genau in diese Länder.
Äh wo die Faschisten gerade aufstrebende Strömung sind. Und Kinder zieht euch warm an und es ist echt nicht mehr witzig und es ist jetzt die Zeit,
dass wir uns,
wirklich einfallen lassen müssen, wie wir dagegen vorgehen. Und es ist echt, ich meine, ich kann die Antwort darauf heute nicht geben, ähm.
Aber man kann auf jeden Fall sagen, dass die bisherigen Strategien,
Wie sie ausprobiert wurden, nicht funktioniert haben. So, wir haben diesen Brexit. Wir haben diese AfD,
Wir haben diesen Trump und ich frage mich ernsthaft, was das für eine Welt zwanzig, sechzehn, siebzehn, achtzehn, zwanzig werden soll, mit solchen Vollpfosten,
In den in den politisch wichtigsten Ämtern und an einflussreichen Stellen für unsere Gesellschaft. So. Ich bin bekennender äh aufgeklärter Rationalist,
Ich hab meine meine politische Position wo ich irgendwie sag OK so glaub ich 'ne Gesellschaft ausgerichtet werden muss daran kann es,
Von mir aus sogar auch äh in diesem Rahmen kann es ähm andere Ausrichtungen geben, ja? Und sagen, nee, wir wir wollen freien Markt statt ähm.
Irgendwie gleiche Chancen oder sowas, ne? Das kann man das alles noch in so einem Diskussionswürdigenrahmen. Aber zu sagen äh,
Ich habe keinen Bock, ihr kommt alle in den Knast. Ähm die ganzen Mexikaner schiebe ich ab und dann baue ich eine Mauer und ihr seid alle doof und Hillowy Clinton ist böse und äh also das ist irgendwie so
offenkundiges, also dieser Mensch ist sowas von nicht in der Lage, ein Land zu regieren. Und sowas von psychisch gestört,
der hat jetzt irgendwie Zugang zu Atomwaffen und der NSA.
Und alles und hat es noch damit hingekriegt, dass er irgendwie als Milliardär sich hinstellt und sagt, ey übrigens ich gehöre nicht zum Establishment,
So bitte was? Also was äh weißt du, wenn man wenn man feststellt, dass es dem Land schlecht geht
dieser Typ hat doch die ganzen Schwarzarbeiter irgendwie aus den aus äh aus Mexiko und so weiter äh rangeschafft und den Stahl aus China gekauft, um irgendwie seine seine seine
Penisprothesen da in die Landschaft zu setzen und und sagt dann am Ende, das geht so nicht in Ordnung, dass die Halloween Clinton Schuld, ja? Ähm.
Oh man, okay. Also es ist wirklich eine Katastrophe und ich bin einfach nur ähm.
Ich warte auf den Tag, wo die Wähler das merken, weil dann gibt es wirklich Blut in den Straßen.
Tja, ist die Frage, ob sie das merken, aber ich denke.
Dieser typisch aufgeklärte gewisser Hinsicht auch linker Ansatz, den wir jetzt die ganze Zeit fahren,
Ja, der bei dir auch rausklingt. Dieses, es kann doch nicht sein, dass man das nicht merkt, es kann doch nicht sein, dass so ein Verhalten und so eine Position und so weiter. Offensichtlich geht's ja schon,
Und man muss sich halt fragen, warum eigentlich.
Warum spielt das sozusagen auf einmal alles überhaupt gar keine Rolle? Und was meiner Auffassung nach oder meiner Wahrnehmung nach dieser,
Jetzt gerade mal eine anderthalb Woche laufende Nachberichterstattung. Ähm auf jeden Fall unterschätzt wurde ist.
Einerseits, also kurze Eindrückung noch, USA ohnehin komisches Land, nur die Hälfte der Leute wählt, ja.
Ja
Und ein Wahlsystem, was jetzt demjenigen, der weniger Stimmen bekommen hat quasi den Gewinn zugeschoben hat. Das ist nochmal ein Problem für sich. Aber
Sagen wir mal ganz gnädig und ich rechne das jetzt einfach mal hoch auf irgendwie es hätte fast jeder gewählt, das wäre aber trotzdem so ausgegangen. Wissen wir nicht, ob das so gewesen wäre. Letzten Endes ist ja nicht wählen auch ein Teil der politischen Äußerung, muss man halt einfach so akzeptieren, wie es passiert ist. Offensichtlich gab es also
Gründe, warum man, obwohl das alles irgendwie Bullshit ist und ich würde noch nicht mal sagen, dass keiner das sieht.
Glaube sogar, dass Leute ihnen einfach nur noch als das wahrgenommen haben, was er wahrscheinlich auch war. Eine Inszenierung.
Man muss ja nur die Interviews anschauen, gleich nach der Wahl. Ja, wie er da auf einmal gerade gefressen hat und was denn doch äh Hillary Clinton für eine verdienstvolle Familie und so weiter, ja, ich meine,
tolle Personen und so. Da ist also der ist sozusagen direkt von du stinkst und äh du bist korrupt auf,
Danke für deinen Beitrag für das Land gewechselt in in Notheim. So. Also man merkt schon, das war eine totale Inszenierung und ich glaube auch,
dass das viele auch so gesehen haben. Also er war einfach nur noch ein Event. Er war sozusagen so eine, so eine, so eine Spaßbude und sie haben sich daran ergötzt.
Wie er so an ihre unterschwelligen Gefühle äh appelliert hat und da so eine Show gemacht hat, weil er dann quasi,
Das repräsentiert was.
So eine Gemeinsamkeit ausdrückt, eine merkwürdige, komisch schwer zu verstehende Gemeinsamkeit. Äh es gab eine schöne Analyse im äh Deutschlandradio gab's irgendwie so eine Sendung, wo äh
Willst du den Namen gerade nicht äh parat? Kommunikationswissenschaftlerin, die so gesagt hat, ja klar, er hat halt einfach.
Mit seiner ganzen Wortwahl das unterstrichen was halt die Republikaner einfach,
denken und oder beziehungsweise das nach vorne gestellt beim Gegner, was sie verabscheuen, ne, so,
Reinheitsgedanken und so weiter, wird alle irgendwie schmutzig und und dreckig sind und so weiter positioniert man die Leute halt auch einfach in dem Diskurs,
genau so wie die ganze Predigtposition da ist. Also kurz gesagt Trump war eine Inszenierung von ihm selbst und seinen Leuten.
Sicherlich war da nichts davon oder nicht alles davon wörtlich so gemeint. Manches leider schon, was bedrohlich ist, aber,
welche Teile davon jetzt sind, das werden wir jetzt erst noch erfahren,
Und die größere Gefahr geht auch sicherlich jetzt nicht von ihm selber aus, sondern äh von den Leuten, die er quasi äh zulässt jetzt hier äh Entscheidungen einzuleiten. Aber trotzdem.
Gibt's diese Unzufriedenheit? Diese Unzufriedenheit, die ihm genau dazu führt, ähm dass.
Man eben nicht die Ratio aktiviert. Und das ist auch etwas, was sich so in Deutschland,
beobachtet. Man fragt sich auch bei diesen Leuten, sondern ihr glaubt irgendwie falsche Nachrichten und Lügenpresse und Tralala und so weiter und ihr widersprecht euch auch in eurem eigenen Diskurs eigentlich am laufenden Meter? Was ist irgendwie eure Wut.
Was was ist eigentlich das Ding, was was euch wirklich stört? Und den USA? Ist es halt dieses Establishment? Was glaube ich vollkommen unterschätzt wurde,
dass diese ähm Trennung zwischen dem politischen Apparat,
Washington, wie auch immer man das nennen mag, ja, dem Kongress und so weiter und dem Rest des Landes so stark geworden ist, dass es von,
Ist mir alles egal, macht auch was ihr wollt bis hin zu ist mir jetzt egal welcher Clown jetzt hier gerade vorbei äh äh kommt, aber solange äh die Botschaft ist, wir hauen euch einfach jetzt mal in die Fresse äh dann bin ich dabei,
und das
Das wurde unterschätzt, man hat gedacht, die Frauen würden die Wahl entscheiden, nichts davon zu sehen, ja? Es ist einfach und es hatte mehr damit zu tun, wer kann quasi sein Uhr äh politischen Pool,
Die Demokraten oder die Republikaner besser aktivieren und das hat halt der Schreihals deutlich besser hinbekommen
Also Frau, die sicherlich ihre Verdienste hat, aber die einfach auch so viel Geschichte hat und so äh auch auch äh teilweise auch gar nicht reagieren konnte, deswegen auch diese Angriffe auf Bill Clinton und so weiter. Da wusste er, da kann sie
das Maul nicht aufmachen, weil egal was sie sagt, äh es es wird sie weiter nur ins Verderben reiten.
Also das Ding die Frage ist, wo kommen diese Leute her, ja? Ich glaube, das ist ein, dass das ein sehr viel längere
'ne sehr viel längere Vorgeschichte hat, dass sich dass sich bestimmte wirtschaftliche und soziale Entwicklungen ergeben haben. Und da gibt es sehr wohl auch eine Verantwortung der Politik,
da zu erkennen, was sind die Herausforderungen, denen eine Volkswirtschaft oder ja, also
sehe es jetzt mal nur wirtschaftlich, denen eine Volkswirtschaft in der Zukunft gegenüber steht, ja? Zum Beispiel sowas wie.
Keine Ahnung, unsere Stahlindustrie geht weg. Unsere Autoindustrie geht unter oder unsere Autoindustrie darf nicht untergehen. Und plötzlich hast du einen Haufen ähm.
Von Arbeitslosen,
Dann hast du, dann kommt dazu, dass du eine Bildungspolitik fährst, insbesondere in den USA, in Deutschland ist das noch bei bei weitem nicht so schlimm. Die Ergebnisse sind aber die gleichen, dass du eine Bildungspolitik fährst, die mehr oder weniger.
Äh Klassenunterschiede manifestiert,
Ja? Also die Leute die also Kinder von Eltern mit geringem Einkommen und geringer Bildung werden geringe Bildung und geringes Einkommen haben. Kinder von Eltern mit hohem Einkommen werden,
höheres Einkommen haben, Kinder von Eltern mit hoher Bildung werden höhere Bildung haben. Und diese ähm
Diese Klassenunterschiede oder Schichtenunterschiede in der Gesellschaft die werden manifestiert, die die Pflanzen sich vor, die ziehen sich durch die Generation und die gehen auseinander,
Vor allem wenn dann auf einmal für die Niedrigqualifizierten die Arbeitsmöglichkeiten wegfallen und das wird nochmal viel schlimmer in Zukunft werden, ne? Mit Automatisierung und solchen Scherzen.
Und da hättest du natürlich politisch ähm lange gegensteuern können, wenn du dafür gesorgt hättest, dass du eine Volkswirtschaft von Hochqualifizierten schaffst.
Die in den Export geht oder die, die halt das Geld aus anderen Ländern bekommt, dafür,
hochqualifizierte Tätigkeiten zu erledigen. Und dafür musst du dir eben die Leute, musst du in die Bildungspolitik investieren, um dir die Leute von von den,
niedrigeren Bildungs und Einkommensschichten nach oben zu katapultieren
In den USA ist das so, dass äh das ja alles magt und so, muss ja alles investiert werden. Wir sagen also, pass auf, wenn du, wenn du hier so eine College-Erziehung haben willst, mit der du ein besseres Einkommen kriegst, dann handelt es sich dabei um eine Investition
Diese Investitionen helfen dir in der Regel, wenn überhaupt äh deine Eltern äh oder eben ein Stunde,
zu erfüllen und wenn du dann aus dem College raus bist, dann marschierst du halt irgendwie mit sowas wie
sechzigtausend Dollar Schulden aufwärts ins Berufsleben und kannst die abbezahlen. Das sind Summen, äh, die eben in den, in den unteren Bevölkerungsschichten gar nicht zur Debatte stehen, ja oder beziehungsweise wo es auch gar keine Förderung gibt, um um die Leute dahin zu bekommen, das überhaupt Aussicht auf so eine äh Universitäts
Bildung hätten und genau das fällt dir jetzt auf die Füße, dass du nämlich diese Leute mit geringerer Bildung ökonomisch abgeschnitten hast.
Und die gleichzeitig durch das niedrige Bildungsniveau noch nicht mal an dem Punkt mehr hast, dass die irgendwie äh das politische System überhaupt verstanden haben,
Die wissen einfach nur, ich bin hier unten, mir wurde versprochen, dass ich durch ehrliche Arbeit äh ein ehrliches Leben führen kann.
Ne? Es gab ein, es gab ein Versprechen, ich bin hier in diesem Land aufgewachsen, mir wurde gesagt, mir wurde gesagt, amerikanischer Traum, wenn ich genug Teller wasche, dann bin ich irgendwann Millionär,
ja? Mit diesem, ja, natürlich, das haben die doch Jahrzehnte lang erzählt bekommen und dann haben die äh haben die sich mitunter in irgendwelchen Industriejobs kaputt geschuftet.
Jahrhundertelang. Ich meine, das wird da auch immer noch erzählt. Es wird auch noch erzielt werden, ja.
So und dann äh dann haben die sich mitunter in irgendwelchen Industriejobs kaputt geschuftet oder sind in Kriege gezogen, im, am Militär, aber haben nirgendwo mal, sage ich mal,
das bekommen, was sich zu einem äh wovon Demokratie ausgeht, dass du nämlich irgendwie halbwegs gebildeter den Fakten und rationalen Erwägungen zugänglicher Mensch bist,
der sich in dieser Demokratie äh.
Betätigt. Und wenn du jetzt einfach mal zwanzig Jahre hinter dir hast, wo du siehst, mir geht es immer schlechter, mir wird immer noch das Blaue vom Himmel versprochen,
Blühende Landschaften werden hier mal so ein Stichwort. Ähm und sagst du, ist mir, das ist völlig egal, was dir vorne labern. Mir ist das,
ganz kack egal, mir kann es gar nicht beschissener gehen, als es mir jetzt geht. Jetzt will ich das System brennen sehen,
und dann kommen genau diese Sachen, die Argumente sind ja die gleichen hier, die Ausländer nehmen uns die Arbeitsplätze. Nein, Quatsch, dieser diese Arbeitsplätze willst du doch überhaupt nicht haben. Und ähm,
das, das geht jetzt in eine ganz fürchterliche, explosive Mischung und da können wir uns warm anziehen.
Ja, ich werde mir nochmal ein bisschen nochmal auf so zwei Sachen raus ähm.
Erstmal nochmal dieses ich glaube was man auch hier nur so begrenzt versteht, was auch ich nur sehr begrenzt verstehe, weil ich bin echt kein kein Amerika-Kenner. So, das ist so das was ich so destiliere aus aus dem was ich,
Andere Leute reflektieren höher so, ne. Zunächst einmal diese Wahl.
Nun Bundestagswahl in Deutschland wird glaube ich sehr viel mehr als betrifft mich wahrgenommen.
Eben ist irgendwie klar oder die aller aller meisten Leuten in Deutschland ist irgendwie klar die Auswirkung der Bundeswahl Bundestagswahl und Wahl zur Bundeskanzlerin Bundeskanzler.
Hat unmittelbare Auswirkungen auf äh das meiste, was hier so politisch äh abgeht. Es gibt natürlich immer noch regionale Dinge, aber die Bedeutung ist hoch. Die Wahrnehmung dieser Bedeutung ist hoch.
Ja und jetzt möchtest du sagen, dass wir in USA nicht so.
Die ist in den USA nicht in dem selben Maße so.
Deckt sich überhaupt nicht mit meiner Erfahrung. Ganz im Gegenteil. Also wirklich radikales Gegenteil.
Also ich hab ja mehrere US-Wahlen mitbekommen in diesem Land seiend und auch in diesem Land lebend,
die Debatte über die ähm über die Präsidentschaftswahl wird sehr viel länger.
Und ausführlicher in allen Gesellschaftsschichten geführt, als das in Deutschland der Fall wäre. Tatsächlich.
Ja, aber hast du dich in einer Stadt befunden oder hast du dich äh.
Ich habe das,
mit mit ländlichen als auch mit städtischen Leuten. Ich habe äh zur zur ersten Wahl von US-Präsident Busch ein Jahr in Amerika gelebt mit in Anführungszeichen der,
niedrig gebildeten, weißen Unterschicht, die den auch gewählt hat,
ich kenn diese Debatten und das ist ein Thema was die sehr sehr detailliert beschäftigt. In völlig beknackten Themen also in USA spielt ja echt immer ähm diese diese Sache mit den.
Mit Abtreibung immer noch eine Rolle, ne? Ähm aber die das debattieren die ähm länger und ausführlicher als das in Deutschland der Fall ist,
An falschen Themen oder so, aber die sehen das spezifisch auch als sie betreffend an. So kann ich, also habe ich wirklich mit so mit Leuten also sage ich mal Leute, die wo du in Deutschland.
Von von der Schicht oder Klasse nicht erwarten würdest, dass sie sich mit einer Wahl auseinandersetzen, äh mit denen hast du da sehr wohl äh Debatten geführt.
Also es ist tatsächlich ne wirklich meine meine Erfahrung. Ich habe ähm auch schon vor einem.
Ziemlich genau ein Jahr vor der Wahl als Trump äh angekündigt hat, dass er kandidieren würde, habe ich mit meinen äh New Yorker Freunden schon über die Wahl debattiert. Da war noch nicht klar, wer überhaupt äh Kandidat wäre, ne? Da haben die alle gesagt, ja, das wird Sanders gegen Trump.
Und ähm und dann wird Sanders gewinnen. Ähm das war so deren äh deren Prognose oder oder nach irgendwie so, dass die Sachen so kommen. Also
der Trump wittet nun wirklich nicht, ne? Also die hatten schon vor schon lange vorher war das Thema. Also, dass das irgendwie an den Leuten vorbei streicht und als Fern oder betrifft mich nicht ähm wahrgenommen würde, deckt sich nicht mit meiner Erfahrung.
Okay, lass mich anders äh formulieren, was ich versuche, da zum Ausdruck äh zu bringen. Es gibt ja diese grundsätzliche,
ähm Staats,
Folgen. Also Government, so, the government im Sinne von, dass Faderal Government, so.
Insbesondere bei den Republikanern, ja, ist so dieses starke Staat ist eigentlich gar nicht so,
hoch angesehen, sondern man will, dass der Staat sich irgendwie raushält, ja? Wir wollen hier mit unseren Waffen rumlaufen und wir machen hier unser Lokal, irgendwie unser Ding, äh, Washington hat hier irgendwie keine Bedeutung, zumindest halten wir mal jetzt in diesen
Russbild und ähm Bible Bellt und,
was halt so die digitalen in in New York und äh San Francisco so als Flyover Candri nennt, ne? Was ja auch eine interessante ähm Herablassung auch schon mal ist, ne. Und ähm.
Also das ist das, was ich meine. Wir haben hier in Deutschland so eine generelle Akzeptanz, so States wir.
Der Einzelne Max differenzierter Seen, aber ich würde sagen, in der, in der Masse ist das schon sehr internationiert, so. Wir wir sind irgendwie auch dieser dieser Staat und dieser Staat ist auch wir. Und ähm,
Das ist etwas, was ich halt in den USA anders sehe. Da da gibt es eine größere Distanz. Die mag hier eine Rolle gespielt haben und,
Letztlich ging's natürlich auch um Identität, ne, so dieses wer sind wir? Wo geht's denn hin? So, jetzt sind die letzten zwanzig Jahre vorbei gestrichen. Du hast äh
Globalisierung der der Produktion erlebt, vieles von dem, was in den USA produziert wurde, wird mittlerweile in Asien produziert, wo es billiger und.
Teilweise auch eben besser äh produziert worden konnte. Das hat eben gerade diesen Russ Bild äh so geschwächt, weil halt einfach diese diese Basis, Automobilindustrie et cetera äh nicht mehr dieselbe Bedeutung hat,
Wie ist das eben damals gehabt? Hat nur auch überhaupt nicht absehbar ist, wie ist diese wieder äh erhalten können, egal wie viel äh wie sehr du da die Ölindustrie oder die Kohleindustrie noch weiter fordern möchtest und,
Offenbar gab's einfach eine eine Identitätskrise.
Rein wirtschaftliche Fragen auch hinaus ging, deswegen konnte sich auch dieser ganze Rassismus in dieser diese Debatte so stark halten.
Und merkst halt jetzt so so eine klare Trennung zwischen diesen diesen liberalen Gegenden in Kalifornien und äh um New York herum und ich weiß nicht, wo noch so ein paar andere Pockets sind. Wahrscheinlich im Prinzip die ganze ähm ganze Bestküste vor allem.
Ähm,
wo die einfach gar nicht mehr miteinander diskutieren können. Ich meine, kam ja auch gleich gleich hier so der erste digitale Pionier, der meint so, ja, jetzt müssen wir hier mal New California äh ausrufen und äh
starten jetzt hier so unsere schottische Unabhängigkeitsbewegung, werdet schon sehen, wo ihr hinkommt, weil wir haben hier irgendwie die Wirtschaftsmacht
keine Ahnung, wohin das führen kann. Ist wahrscheinlich nichts, was von heute auf morgen passiert. Aber diese Brücke ist halt.
Nicht gebaut worden und die beiden Teile kommen irgendwie nicht mehr zusammen und das war ein weiterer Faktor, der einfach dann dazu geführt hat, dass die Leute gesagt haben, ja scheiß auf euch. Wir wählen jetzt hier irgendwie den den dicken mit dem schlechten Haar.
Mir egal was dann passiert. Schlimmer kann's ja nicht werden.
Da werden wir noch sehen. Ja.
Der.
Jetzt haben wir auch noch die Wahl hergeleitet, wollten wir eigentlich auch nicht machen, aber.
Wollen wir nicht machen, vielleicht sollten wir nochmal den sozusagen so einen zweiten Diskurs äh folgen lassen, wo wir mal so diesen netzpolitischen Aspekt vielleicht nochmal in den Mittelpunkt rücken.
Ja jetzt haben wir ein Trump, der schönen Zugriff hat auf eine ganze Menge Gesetzgebung, die wenn man's nicht so wohlwollend auslegt, der auch eine ganze Menge äh.
Ärger erzeugen kann.
Ja, wir haben vor allem einen schönen, ein NSA unter Trump jetzt, ne? Also das sollte vielleicht auch der Bundesregierung äh mal bei ihrer ganzen BND Gesetzgebung äh ein kleines Denk.
Anstößchen sein
wie schnell dieser ganze Mist, weil unter der Maßgabe, wir sind ja die Guten in der Hand des eindeutig bösen und nicht qualifizierten landen kann.
Was wir ja immer schon gesagt haben.
Was wir immer schon gesagt.
Nicht die Werkzeuge, die am Ende missbraucht werden können, wenn die falschen an die Macht kommen.
Sondern erhaltet diese Kontrolle, diese Checks und Balances und das ist halt in USA besonders problematisch, wenn man sich anschaut, was so ein Präsident so tun darf im Prinzip
Ja, also ob er das auch alles dann äh so tun kann, wird sich dann äh konkret zeigen, aber besser man kommt irgendwie erst gar nicht erst an diesen Punkt,
wo das alles dann nur noch so von einem neurotischen Menschen äh abhängt, ja, der mit Persönlichkeitsstörung und wenn der jetzt sogar nach seiner Wahl.
Jetzt irgendwie damit beschäftigt ist auf Twitter.
Auf die New York Times einzuhauen und sich in einem Interview hast du das gesehen, diese Sixty Minutes Interview mit Trump fasst ja auch echt an den Kopf,
Man hat so das Gefühl gehabt, der berauscht sich im Wesentlichen da drin, dass er irgendwie seit der Wahl hunderttausend neue Follower auf Twitter hat. Das, ich meine, das hat er gesagt.
Wie geil es doch wäre. Äh der hunderttausend neue Follower Filler. Alter, du bist der Fucking Präsident von dem fucking USA geworden.
Scheiß auf deinen Twitter-Account, ey. Den kannst du auch, du heißt sowieso bald Potos irgendwie.
Das wollen wir nochmal sehen. Also ich könnte mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass der Obama den Twitter das wird noch so ein Flamo auf Twitter.
Nein, nein, das hat, das hat ja das schon geregelt. Also äh Twitter hat da ein neues Feature eingebaut, dass quasi Obama übernimmt, seine Follower mit einem anderen Account.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob Put.
Fotos aber dann auch, der, also sozusagen Fotos wird dann aufgesplittet und die teilen sich dann irgendwie die Follower oder so, also wir nehmen die alten. Also es ist auf jeden Fall geregelt.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall äh es gibt noch eine man muss ja dazu sagen, der äh.
Trump müsste jetzt noch von den Wahlmännern gewählt werden. Ähm das theoretisch könnte es sein, dass es nicht geschieh,
Ähm nur das ist eben auch keine praktische,
Variante, weil du dann natürlich die, die absoluten äh Ausbruch äh hättest, ne? Also wenn du an als wenn du an eine Wahl antrittst mit dem mit der klaren Aussage diese Wahl ist manipuliert.
Dann was ist alles so fürchterlich,
Es ist alles so fürchterlich. Wir haben hunderte von Jahren mit der Menschheit darauf hingewirkt, dass man mit so einem Scheiß einfach nicht mehr durchkommt. Und das geht alles den den Bach runter. Ja, es ist wirklich zum heulen. Ich möchte jetzt über was anderes reden.
Keinen despolitischen Aspekt mehr irgendwie. Ich meine außer NSA,
Meine ich frage mich halt, wie steht eigentlich diese äh.
Super Hardcore Ultra rechte Fraktion, die da jetzt zusammenfegt, mit seinen ganzen Kindern da im Transischen Team ist ja äh ohnehin auch nochmal mega albern, aber er war sehr kritisch, wozu wie Freihandels,
Dings, das wahrscheinlich alles wie Bullshit, was da äh gesagt w.
Vor allem nicht netzpolitisch.
Aber diese diese sagen wir mal die Diskussion um Netz neutralität und überhaupt die zukünftige Gestaltung von Kommunikationsregeln im Internet, Zensur, et cetera und so weiter. Das macht mir eigentlich in der Hinsicht am meisten Sorgen.
Ja, da können wir dann andere mal drüber reden. Ich habe jetzt einfach keine Lust mehr, weil jetzt eine Stunde Sendung und äh ich möchte da jetzt einfach nicht mehr drüber reden.
Vor allem ist auch müßig. Dieser Typ ist krank und redet jeden Tag was anderes. Lasst uns abwarten, bis er mal was macht. Also er hat ja jetzt auch von, der hat ja wirklich jede politische Handlung und ihr Gegenteil zugesichert
Das Einzige, was er wirklich fest zugesagt hat, ist diese Mauer. Mal gucken, äh wann.
Davon ist er auch schon wieder weg.
Ist er auch schon wieder.
Wird den Scheiß auch nicht mitspielen, ja? Wenn der irgendwann mal was macht, dann können wir uns darüber können wir uns damit auseinandersetzen, ähm.
Aber sonst sehe ich da jetzt gerade keine Veranlassung auf der Trompete weiterzuspielen.
Trump Peter.
So, kommen wir mal äh zu also.
BSI und Innenministerium äh stellen jedes Jahr äh den die den IT-Sicherheitsbericht vor und äh wir haben jetzt in diesem Jahr auch eine neue IT-Sicherheitsstrategie vorgestellt. Ähm.
Das ist äh
Im Prinzip interessant, also es gab einen sehr schönen Kommentar auf Heise, der irgendwie lautete, die die neue Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie der Bundesregierung ist quasi die Alte, Entschuldigung, heißt nicht IT-Sicherheitsstrategie, sondern Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie, ne, da geht es dann um das
nationale Cyber-Abwehrzentrum, das soll weiter ausgebaut werden, dann äh geht es darum, dass das BSI äh,
Diese Mobile Incellent Response Teams bekommen soll, also schneller vor Ort äh zum Einsatz sein soll.
Und insbesondere natürlich ist die Rede von der Zitis der zentralen.
Stelle für Telekommunikation und wo habe ich das denn? Das ist ich hatte oh Scheiße, ich hatte diesen Begriff so schön rausgesucht. Ähm was zieht es nochmal heiß, Zentralstelle für IT-Sicherheit und so weiter. Man Tim hilft doch mal, wo bist.
Ich überlege doch auch gerade.
Ja, man unmöglich, ey. So, das ist die äh der Begriff war so komisch ähm.
Zentralstelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich. Genau. Dieser Titel hat aber überhaupt nichts damit zu tun, ähm was wir eigentlich machen sollen, nämlich den Aufgabe soll ja sein ähm.
Eine Zusammenarbeit ähm mit,
zwischen den Bundespolizei und den Geheimdiensten zu schaffen und,
Die Forschung zum Umgehen von verschlüsselter Kommunikation voranzutreiben für Polizei und Geheimdienste. Gleichermaßen, ja? Also eine wir reden hier von einer Zentralstelle im Bundesinnenministerium,
die heute schon Behörde genannt wird, aber keine ist.
Und die sowohl für Geheimdienste als auch für Polizei quasi Dienstleistungen erbringen sollen und beide ermächtigen soll äh Verschlüsselung zu knacken,
Das Spannende ist, die soll im Januar zwanzig siebzehn ihre Arbeit aufnehmen und da gibt's aber keine explizite Rechtsgrundlage für, denn es diese Zitis soll als.
Quasi als Arbeitsgruppe oder als irgendwie Ressort im Innenministerium,
erstmal fungieren. Und das Spannende daran ist, wenn du das so machst, also im Innenministerium kannst du natürlich Büros für sonst was äh gründen. So, das schreibt dir keiner vor.
Wenn du aber eine Behörde schaffen möchtest, dann brauchst du dafür ein Gesetz,
Da brauchst du ein Gesetz, das sagt, wir haben jetzt die Behörde so und so und das ist dann das, so was heißt dann eben BKA-Gesetz, BND-Gesetz, äh
Datenschutzgesetz, hast du alles nicht gesehen. Da gibt es dann eine ein Gesetz, in dem festgestellt wird
Die Bundesrepublik Deutschland unterhält eine Behörde mit dem Namen so und so. BSI-Gesetz, ja, hast du alles und äh ein ziehtes Gesetz gibt es nicht,
Das heißt, die oder noch nicht, wird's dann irgendwann mal geben, aber weil man ein solches Gesetz ja,
quasi aus dem Kabinett in den Bundestag geben würde und dann einer öffentlichen Debatte
zugrunde legen müsste, dann müsste das durch die Ausschüsse. Dann hättest du auf einmal Sachverständige da sitzen. Die sagen dir dann auf einmal, das ist Mist, was du da machst. Das geht verfassungsrechtlich gar nicht. Dagegen klagen wir. Dann hast du ein Gesetz, wogegen geklagt werden kann,
Diesen ganzen Ärger sparst du dir, wenn du das einfach so machst. Und das ist das, was hier gerade passiert.
Aber welchen Status, welchen rechtlichen Status hat es denn dann, wenn es eigentlich gar keine Behörde sein kann? Ist das dann nur so eine Arbeitsgruppe, die so gut ausgestattet ist, wie du normalerweise Behörden.
Nie Details, ja? Ähm aber es geht ähm eben darum, dass es explizit
keine Behörde ist, sondern irgendwie eine Zentralstelle so, das wird dann irgendwann mal die Behörde werden, aber bis jetzt ist das eine Arbeitsgruppe.
Das sind ist halt eine Zentralstelle. Die haben wahrscheinlich auch alle nur Lichtbild aus.
Genau, aber sie soll irgendwann eine Bundesbehörde werden, ist es aber jetzt noch nicht. Und wurde auch als Bundesbehörde angekündigt, ja, aber ähm.
Bundesbehörde in Gründung.
Genau. So und äh sie bis zweitausendzweiundzwanzig soll die ja dann auf vierhundert Mitarbeiter anwachsen
aber bis jetzt ist das erstmal so das gibt's jetzt, ist jetzt halt eine Zentralstelle.
Ist auch ein äh elegante Methode, sowas zu machen.
Könnten wir ja Lea auch magen.
Hör mal auf. Dann äh.
Genau, dann werden wir aber niemals Behörde und wahrscheinlich wollen wir das auch nicht werden. Ähm dann,
sagt er, sagt dieser IT-Sicherheits äh die Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie, man möchte die Zusammenarbeit von Staat und Wirtschaft Wirtschaft stärken, ja? Ähm.
Denn da wird unter dieser schönen Überschrift verbiegt sich dann die Cyberwehr, über die wir ja schon äh hier gesprochen haben.
Und dann wird irgendwie groß gezeigt, hier äh Propaganda und Meinungsspots. Ja, also äh dieses Social Bots, die äh Wahlen manipulieren, ja. Ähm ich will das Thema Social Bots jetzt an dieser Stelle nicht vertiefen. Ähm.
Ich habe mich da ja mehrmals auch zu geäußert. Ich werde ja auch im Januar nochmal im Bundestag was zu sagen, ähm weil ich da in in so einer Expertenanhörung sein werde. Ähm.
Man wird das nochmal analysieren müssen, was da jetzt, wie, wie groß die Gefahr wirklich ist. In anderen News sagte jetzt der Mazia, dass er eigentlich gerne hätte
dass alle Parteien quasi so eine freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung eingehen, dass bei der bundesweit zwanzig siebzehn nicht zu machen. Gleichzeitig gibt's jetzt schon erste einfache Facebook-Recherchen, die zeigen, dass die AfD über sowas schon verfügt,
Die AfD hatte auch schon angekündigt, dass sie äh nicht beabsichtigt äh sich da nicht dran zu halten. Das ist also hier Cybersicherheitsstrategie ne viel,
Bohai A hier schauen sie dort ein Meinungsbot und ähm gleichzeitig in Wirklichkeit, was wir aber da haben ist Cyber-Abwehrzentrum.
Ähm freiwilligen Armee aus der Wirtschaft und äh Netzitis, die in Zukunft unsere Verschlüsselung knacken soll. Das ist also die Cyber-Sicherheitsstrategie.
Die wurde zusammen veröffentlicht mit dem Lagebericht IT-Sicherheit des des BSI. Und der Lagebericht IT-Sicherheit ist ähm.
Das ist so ein Ding. Ähm der wurde ursprünglich, also der den ersten Lagebericht IT-Sicherheit in Deutschland gab es glaube ich zweitausendfünf,
Veröffentlicht vom Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik. Dann haben die das ein paar
eine Zeit lang so alle zwei Jahre gemacht, ich glaube zweitausendsieben, zweitausendneun und dann seit zweitausendelf gab's den eigentlich jedes Jahr, dann hieß er nur einmal anders
Und dann wurde aber mit dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, was ja letztes Jahr, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, äh richtig in Erinnerung habe, debattiert wurde. Das Versprechen gegeben, dass BSI würde jetzt einen Lagebericht der IT-Sicherheit verfassen,
Und dafür ähm äh,
unterwerfe es eben auch die verschiedenen äh Bereiche der kritischen Infrastrukturen dieser Meldepflicht,
Ja? Da war dann ein ein schöner ähm äh ein schöner Moment im Innenausschuss, wenn ich das Recht entsinne, als ich den ähm scheidenden BSI-Präsidenten
Herrn Hanke darauf hinwies, dass seine Behörde das Ding seit zweitausendfünf rausgibt und das jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen amüsant ist, dass hier nochmal neu äh
Anzu äh neu zu bewerben, ja? Aber okay, lassen wir das. Der Hernke ist äh aus dem Amt geschieden. Wir haben inzwischen.
Den Arne Schönburm als äh BSI-Präsidenten. Und jetzt seid in Kraft treten des ähm.
Und das IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes ist das jetzt der erste äh der erste Lagebericht der IT-Sicherheit. Ne, das ist also ein Versprechen der ähm das uns mit dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz noch einmal gemacht wurde. Ähm.
Interessant ist, dass dieser Meldepflicht bisher nur noch nicht alle Bereiche der kritischen Infrastrukturen,
unterliegen. Das ist ähm wenn ich das richtig,
sehr ähm bisher Telekommunikation und Energie und
Kernenergie oder so, die diesen dieser Meldepflichten schon unterliegen
aber noch nicht noch nicht alle Bereiche, also kritische Infrastruktur umfasst dann auch noch irgendwie viele andere Bereiche. Es geht runter bis zur Versicherung und Nahrungsmittelversorgung. Die dem noch nicht unterliegen.
Ähm das kommt also erst nach und nach, ne? Per ähm erlass des Innenministeriums, wenn ich das Recht in Erinnerung habe. Nun,
Wir erhalten also diesen diesen Lagebericht und ich hatte gestern Abend komme ich gleich auch nochmal drauf zurück, so ein Anruf vom,
vom Deutschlandfunk und die sagten, hören sie mal, können sie morgen früh mal irgendwie ein bisschen was zu diesem äh IT äh zu dieser CIT-Lage sagen, ne? Habe ich gesagt, kein Problem,
Den Bericht habe ich eh schon in meiner Inbox. Ich erzähle ihnen da morgen was zu. Da macht dich dieses PDF auf einen Schrecken. Ich bin hinten übergefallen. Sechsundachtzig Seiten. Vorher waren das immer so Liparello, es kann Zeit nicht sagen, ne,
und ich dachte so, oh Heiland, jetzt müsst ihr das alles lesen, ne?
Und ähm dann habe ich aber irgendwie eine ähm in das Inhaltsverzeichnis geschaut und dann hast du irgendwie bis Seite einunddreißig, hast du im Prinzip nur so allgemein Wissen und Binsenweisheiten,
Äh wo dann irgendwie so Begriffe erklärt werden so, ne? Also hier, es gibt ähm Derby,
Die Leute, es gibt Detox-Attacken. Es gibt Spam, es gibt Fishing, es gibt Fake President Attacken äh und was es nicht alles gibt. Da wird dann so ähm Allgemeinwissen IT-Sicherheitslage vermittelt. Was nicht schlecht ist
Aber was ähm eben auch jetzt quasi für die Branche nichts neues sein dürfte.
Du musst es dir das jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht mehr im Detail durchlesen.
Musste ich mir im Detail nicht mehr durchlesen. Ähm bin dann natürlich über so interessante Formulierungen gestolpert wie die Anzahl der bekannten Schwachstellen ist zweitausendsechzehn erneut gestiegen,
Äh wo du so denkst so, na ja, wie sollte sie jemals sinken? Äh äh ne, also das Wissen der Welt kann ja nicht abnehmen, ne. Es ist ja,
quasi gut, dass diese Anzahl bekannter Sicherheitslücken gestiegen ist, weil nur dadurch, dass man sie kennt, äh können sie geschlossen werden. Ne, ist aber natürlich auch
gleichzeitig schlecht, weil sie eben da waren. Schöner wäre, wenn sie nicht da gewesen wären. Und wenn ich diese Grafiken da richtig interpretiere, wurden sogar weniger gefunden als zweitausendfünfzehn. Was eigentlich der zu erhoffende Effekt ist, ne? Also die, die absolute Zahl nimmt immer zu, die ist ja kumulativ,
Aber die Zunahme sollte abnehmen.
Beziehungsweise weißt du ja nicht ob sie, wenn sie abnimmt, kann es halt auch heißen, dass du einfach nicht genug gefunden hast, ne? Also dass diese Zeit zunimmt, ist prinzipiell immer.
Eigentlich gut, weil das heißt, dass die Sicherheitslücken auch äh gefixt werden.
Äh dann wurde so ein bisschen über Rancing Ware gesprochen, also diese äh Krypto-Trojaner haben wir, glaube ich, hier ausführlich drüber gesprochen, dann über IOT und so weiter. Dann kommt und jetzt kommt der spannende Teil. Jetzt kommt der quasi der Rechenschaftsbericht BSI
Also wo es wirklich um die Lage der IT-Sicherheit geht, das ist dann äh da geht's dann um die Bundesverwaltung. Da ähm ist das BSI ja äh,
verantwortlich für die Abwehr. Und dann sagt das BSI ja hier ähm.
Unser Lagebericht äh IT-Sicherheit oder Bedrohung, Pipapo. Bundesverwaltung auf vier Seiten,
Wo sie dann mehr oder weniger formulieren. Ja, also aus der Abwehr wissen wir, dass wir vierundvierzigtausend infizierte E-Mails pro Monat in Echtzeit abgefangen haben,
Das ist sehr schön formuliert. Der Begriff, den sie da vermeiden ist, äh Virenscanner, ne? Also das ist das, was ihr da haben.
Vierundvierzigtausend pro Monat. Ja. Also für vierundvierzigtausend unterschiedliche.
Das ist wieder ne, ne, hier ist der Begriff, infizierte E-Mail, ne? Also so so genau sind diese Beschreibungen ja gar nicht. Aber letztendlich sagen sie, wir unterhalten einen ähm einen Viren-Scanner Spam-Filter.
Und ähm dann sagen sie außerdem.
Haben wir bis zu zweihundert Schadsoftwarinfektionen pro Monat.
Das ist also das, was also im Prinzip sagen sie, wir unterhalten einen Spam-Filter, der Masseninfektion rausfiltert und wir haben äh wir unterhalten einen Virenscanner, der ähm.
Der die Leute davon abhält, den Mist zu klicken, der trotzdem durchgekommen ist und dann haben wir noch einige Sachen über äh gezielte Angriffe, ne? Wir haben so ein bisschen Statistiken oder sowas.
Mehr steht da aber jetzt eigentlich nicht drin, ne? So, da sind ein paar Zahlen, die immer natürlich sehr beeindruckend sind und je nachdem in welchen Kontext du die setzt, sind die entweder niedrig oder hoch, aber auf jeden Fall wenig Aussagekraft und das war ja immer das Versprechen des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes, das
dieser Lagebericht ähm quasi helfen würde den Unternehmen,
sich selber
zu stärken oder so, ne? Aber okay, das ist im Prinzip nur der, der, dass man jetzt irgendwie, kann man den BSI auch nicht übel nehmen, dass es sagt, okay, vier Seiten, da erklären wir mal ganz kurz was
bisschen Statistiken, um zu zeigen, wir waren auch tätig, ne? Ähm und dann habe ich gedacht, oh, oh, jetzt kommt der zweite spannende Teil
kritische Infrastruktur, ne? Lagebericht IT-Sicherheit, kritische Infrastruktur, jetzt geht's rund. Ne, jetzt wollen wir mal sehen, was los war. Vier Seiten.
Und auf den vier Seiten werden ähm die Meldungen oder oder die Vorfälle äh im im Bereich der kritischen Infrastrukturen aufgelistet.
Ne, also ist ja Lagebericht. Was gab es denn.
Die ganzen brennenden Kraftwerke stehen da jetzt.
Ganzen brennenden Kraftwerke stehen da drin. Nein, erster Punkt natürlich die Rancy Mear in Krankenhäusern. Klar hat die hat ja auch die
es gab mehrere Fälle, ich glaub das waren zwei, drei große Fälle, in denen Krankenhäuser tatsächlich auch so Betriebsschwierigkeiten hatten, weil ihre IT
einfach nicht ein vernünftiges Backup-System hatte. Und irgendjemand so oh eine oh eine Rechnung mal gucken was hier ist ha o
äh ich sage mal
lieber nichts äh und dann war halt das waren halt irgendwie der größere Teil der des Datenbestandes dieses Krankenhauses halt einem Kryptotrojaner zum Opfer gefallen und ähm,
Ich glaube im in einem Klinikum, wo das Ganze dann auch gegen Zahlung von irgendwie siebzehntausend Euro oder sowas in Bitcoin äh,
äh beigelegt, aber okay, man sieht hier eine unreife auf Seiten der Krankenhausbetreiber. Ähm,
ein vernünftiges Backup und wieder Anlaufkonzept ähm ist eben äh gehört einfach heute dazu. Äh ohne solches kannst du so ein Krankenhaus nicht äh nicht laufen lassen und das haben eben einige jetzt auf die schmerzhafte Weise gelernt.
Nicht mal ein Podcast Studio, kannst du auf so eine Art und Weise laufen lassen?
Ja, äh, nicht mal Linus Neumann kann's auf so 'ne Weise laufen lassen, ich hatte da irgendwie letztens auch äh ne, also lobe du sollst das Backup nicht vor dem Restore loben.
Äh äh geht, ist, weil war nicht nicht besonders tragisch, aber ähm du sollst das Backup nicht vor dem Restorat um. So, also das, ne? Dann ähm.
Immer schön testen. Das ist Backup auch funktioniert, so.
Es ging, ich hatte eigentlich war.
Notstrom, den Notstromgenerator regelmäßig jeden Monat getestet haben und dass es dann soweit war.
War der Akku über der.
Diesel alle, ja.
Ja, es ist alles nicht so einfach, ne? Ähm.
Okay, aber da da muss, es müssen immer ein paar Leute äh sich die Finger verbrennen, damit die Kohle bei den anderen locker gemacht wird, um das Problem anzugehen. Ähm also erster Punkt, kritische Infrastruktur, Rancymeare in Krankenhäusern, ne? Muss man dazu sagen,
Bei den Wendsonware-Angriffen auf Krankenhäuser gab es teilweise wurde dann gesagt, das waren gezielte.
Es gab aber eben auch Fälle von ganz normaler äh Massen äh.
Drive by.
Ja Massenspam, ne? So. Okay. Zweiter Punkt der kritischen Infrastrukturangriffe laut Bericht des BSI. Ein Stromausfall in der Ukraine.
Der war jetzt hier in den Bundes.
Das ist der zweite Punkt. Im Bericht des BSI äh über äh hier eine Gefahr.
In der Ukraine gab's einen Stromausfall. Darüber setzt das BSI uns hier hm in Kenntnis.
Was hat das in dem BSI-Bericht zu tun?
Na ja, ist Gefährdungslage, ne?
In der Ukraine.
Was ist mit denen in Neuseeland und irgendwie.
Weiß es nicht.
Aber das ist das zweite, was wir nennen. In der Ukraine ereignete sich im Dezember zwanzig fünfzehn ein Stromausfall, der offenbar Folge eines koordinierten Cyberangriffs auf mehrere Energie
Netzbetreiber war. Betroffen waren circa zweihundertfünfundzwanzigtausend Einwohner. Vergleiche, Vorfallstromausfallen in der Ukraineseite vierzig.
Betroffene kritische Dienstleistung, Stromversorgung. So, dann haben Sie hier noch ein bisschen, äh, haben Sie hier so 'ne Infobox zu den Cyberangriffen auf das Swiss System, ne? Dann wurden hier glaub ich, haben wir, glaub ich, hier auch
behandelt, wo es dann eben äh erfolgreiche Angriffe unter anderem gegen
die equadorianische Bankkodellaustro mit zwölf Millionen US-Dollar Schaden sowie eine ukrainische Bank ab, äh, zehn Millionen US-Dollar Schaden, Angriffsversuch
auf.
Auf eine vietnamesische Bank dann irgendwie in Banglade, der schon so, ja, also es gab Angriffe auf das Swift System, das hat das BSI mitbekommen, auch hier nichts in Deutschland. Dann benennen sie, es gab drei größere.
Störungen bei IKT Provider, also in äh Telekommunikationsnetz Dienstleistern, die jeweils zwischen siebenhundertfünfzigtausend und zwei Komma sieben Millionen Einwohnern betrafen.
Und bei diesem Ausfall bei diesem zum Ausfall von Internetzugang, Telefonie oder Mobilfunk führen
Also es gab äh drei größere Vorfälle von Netzausfall, ne? Ich weiß gar nicht genau, welche drei das sind, waren, aber es wurde über alle berichtet, ich glaube, der eine Betraf, also einer betraf auf jeden Fall die Telekom.
Mhm.
Ähm die anderen beiden äh einer betraf Vodafone und ich glaube, es gab noch einen im Festnetz. So,
Interessanterweise steht hier nirgendwo, dass Auslöser dafür ein Cyber-Angriff war. Und ähm ich weiß, ich habe da ein paar Hintergrundgespräche geführt und ich weiß, dass zumindest bei zwei davon.
Es nicht ein Cyberangefahr, der zu diesem Ausfall geführt hat. Ähm ich weiß nicht wie viel darüber äh öffentlich bekannt ist,
und ich kann da müsste ich jetzt gucken, aber das war dann äh Betriebsfehler im weiteren Sinne.
Okay.
Ähm kann man wahrscheinlich nachlesen. Also es dürfte eigentlich jetzt nicht so geheim sein, aber weil ich das eben auf Hintergrundgesprächen weiß
sage ich da jetzt nichts zu,
auf jeden Fall keine Cyberangriffe steht hier auch nicht. Ist aber auch nicht unbedingt notwendig, weil ähm das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz ja spezifisch sagt, äh Zwischenfälle, die zu Betriebsstörungen hätten führen können, sind meldepflichtig. In dieser Pflicht sind die Betroffenen
ähm Betreiber hier nachgekommen und deswegen steht das hier drin, ja? Ähm.
Und dann benennen sie noch einen Fall, wo habe ich das denn? Da ging es um ein äh visualisierungsrechner ähm.
Bei einer kerntechnischen Anlage wurde im Rahmen einer Routinerevision.
Eine ein Standard äh Virus äh gefunden.
Ja, also äh die haben irgendwie festgestellt, dass ähm,
dass ein, dass da irgendwie so ein Rechner, der im Rahmen eines, der bei einem ähm bei einem Atomkraftwerk stand.
Von weit verbreiteter Schadsoftware befallen war, die von Virenscannern seit längerer Zeit entdeckt und gut erkannt wurde.
Dieser Visualisierungsrechner selbst lief mit einer nicht mehr aktuellen Betriebssystemversion und verfügte nicht über einen Virenscanner.
So, ja dann passiert sowas, ne? Wenn du äh alte Software benutzt ähm und äh dann irgendwie keine Schutzmaßnahmen hast, dann fällst du eben auch bei Massenangriffen unter die Räder. Und das ist irgendwie mit ähm mit einem USB-Stick oder sowas da zustande gekommen.
Fazit, sie sagen, ja, Anwender setzen auch gängige und einfache Sicherheitsmaßnahmen häufig nicht oder nicht hinreichend um
und es müssen die Verantwortlichkeiten geklärt werden, da muss irgendwie mehr Struktur rein, das ist ein Fazit, da haben sie natürlich Recht mit. Ich war nur überrascht, weil du eben also erstmal hast du
ähm diese einunddreißig Seiten
Vor Wort und Begriffsklärung dann vier Seiten Bundesverwaltung, vier Seiten Kritik, wo mit Ausflügen in alle Länder dieser Erde ähm
und dann eben ein längeres Papier nochmal achtundzwanzig Seiten Cybersicherheit gestalten, ne, wo sie dann sagen, Fischstaat und Verwaltung, für Wirtschaft, für Gesellschaft, ähm wo sie die Rolle des BSI sehen, aber das, was wirklich Lagebericht ist,
sind also hier ähm acht Seiten, mehr ist da nicht. Bin mal gespannt, äh ob das,
ob das dann nochmal zunimmt. Ähm das ist jetzt aber sicherlich kein keine verkehrte Publikation, ne? Nur also als vor dem Hintergrund, dass uns das groß versprochen wurde mit dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und so, ne? Ist das noch ein bisschen dünn.
Wie gesagt, gibt es verschiedene,
mögliche Auslöser und Begründung für warum das so dünn ist, ne? Noch ist nicht alles erfasst, noch findet das BSI sich in diese Position hinein, aber ein bisschen ähm,
ein bisschen äh Sport konnte ich mir da nicht verkneifen. Ähm interessanter dann übrigens, dass äh das Deutschlandradiointerview, was oder Deutschlandfunkinterview, was ich da gerade erwähnt ähm,
das handelte am Ende gar nicht davon.
Was ein bisschen erschreckend war. Äh also ich hatte, ich habe diesen ganzen Bericht da heute Morgen um sieben mir in den Kopf geprügelt und wollte den dann im im Deutschlandfunk bewerten und.
Wollten sie wieder doch nur über Pokemon Go reden oder.
So in der Art äh ging's dann eben um irgendwie Schadsoftware und äh Wirtschaftssabotage, äh die jetzt das Thema wäre. Auslöser war dann der. IT.
Gipfel, der heute stattfindet in Saarbrücken, in Saarbrücken ist IT-Gipfel, hat Sigmar Gabriel ähm heute Morgen geöffnet und direkt mal klargestellt, das ist das letzte Mal, dass das Ding IT-Gipfel heißt, denn nächstes Jahr heißt es.
Cyber-Gipf.
Nein, Digitalgipfel.
Oh
Na ja.
Digital Gipfel.
Ja, da habe ich auf jeden Fall dann wirklich so spontan vor der Moderatorin eine Minute vorher gesagt, ja wir reden dann so ein bisschen über äh Wirtschaftssabotage
Und da kannste dann mal äh,
schwitzenden Linus sehen können, der eben so sagt so, okay, ähm Stunde vorbereitet auf ein anderes Thema und jetzt nochmal schnell ein paar Talking Points mit einem Bleistift äh in den Tisch kratzen, äh die zu diesem Ding äh dann
gelten, aber ist gut gelaufen, haben am Ende äh habe ich die Kurve glaube ich gekriegt und ähm war äh war dann eben heute Morgen kurz im Deutschlandfunk.
Man kommt ja schon auch ein bisschen ins Training, ne? Wenn man irgendwie so oft äh.
Ja, das, also man, das war dann also man sie sagte dann natürlich auch, okay, bitte, ne, machen sie hier keinen Fachvortrag, sondern konzentrieren sie sich auf die Punkte, die man den.
Überbrechen sie es auch noch, schön einfach runter mit.
Für für unsere Hör,
Das sind nicht alles Hacker und dann dann ist das natürlich auch sollte das jetzt jemanden, der sich mit dem Themengebiet regelmäßig auseinandersetzt, jetzt auch nicht,
enorm schwer fallen, ein paar äh Dinge rauszuhauen, die äh da äh vielleicht halbwegs klug sind. Ich war nicht zufrieden, aber ich, es war zumindest nicht so, dass ich äh stammend und gar nichts sagend im im Radio.
Oder dass man da, dass du dich jetzt so schämen würdest, dass dass wir das gar nicht verlinken.
Ja doch kann man auch verlinken. So, aber jetzt hier, weiter geht's. Wichtig, es gibt wichtigeres. Es gibt wichtigeres als äh als den Lagerbericht IT-Sicherheit. Ähm,
Ich würde, ich würde gerne viel mehr über IT-Sicherheit reden, müssen wir gucken, wie wir das hier in diesem Rahmen machen, aber jetzt haben wir schon so viel über Trump und und uns selber geredet, dass sich mehr Themen jetzt hier drin haben will. Deswegen,
reden wir über die Verfassungsbeschwerde von Amnesty äh die jetzt eingereicht wurde,
gegen den gegen die Tätigkeiten des BND. So und da ist also eine,
hier werden wieder die Begriffe Klage und Verfassungsbeschwerde synonym verwendet, auch in den Artikeln, die ich lese
Ich weiß, dass die Leute sich dann auch in den Kommentaren wieder äh melden und sagen, Linus, du kennst noch nicht mal den Unterschied, aber die du die Journalisten von denen ich vorlese, kenne ihn auch nicht. Ähm,
also diese Verfassungsbeschwerde richtet sich gegen ähm mehrere Paragraphen des G zehn Gesetzes. Das G zehn Gesetz, wir erinnern uns,
wird so genannt, weil es Grundgesetzartikel zehn betrifft.
Indem äh das Fernmeldegeheimnis verankert ist. Und jede ähm,
Jede Eingriffe in das Fernmeldegeheimnis, was uns vom Grundgesetz zugesichert ist, dürfen nur auf gesetzlicher Ebene, auf gesetzlicher Basis stattfinden
ne? Das ist quasi das, was das Grundgesetz hier regelt, das sagt nicht, die ist das Ferngemeldegeheimnis ist äh unantastbar,
Aber es sagt, wenn dann muss es hier gesetzlich geregelt sein, dass da was geschieht. Wer dafür kein Gesetz hat, der darf es auch nicht.
Dieses Gesetz wurde neunzehnhundertachtundsechzig erlassen und bereits mehrfach überarbeitet. Ähm insbesondere hatten gegen diese Ermächtigung des BND zur Daten
Hörung, ähm Journalisten schon Ende des äh Ende der neunziger Jahre äh geklagt. Und neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig,
befand Karlsruhe, also des Bundesverfassungsgericht, aber alles für okay.
Was also die Datenabhörkapazitäten, die das BN, die das die BND mit der Gesetzentgesetzesänderung hatte. Ähm.
Anging und dann wurden zweitausendeins die Kompetenzen des äh BND nochmal erweitert. So, jetzt,
Kommt der Kniff. Zuletzt überarbeitet wurde das ähm.
G zehn Gesetz zweitausend im Herbst zweitausendfünfzehn und da wurden Cyber-Gefahren als Legitimationsgrund mit aufgenommen. Da wurde gesagt, ihr dürft außerdem das Fernmeldegeheimnis verletzen,
und Daten abschnorcheln zum Erkennen von Cybergefahren. Darüber hatten wir, glaube ich, in Logbuchnetzwedik, vor allem mit André Meister gesprochen, der hatte das äh ich weiß nicht, ob der,
Ob der da selber Zuck, also der war auf jeden Fall hier zu Gast. Ich glaube in Vertretung für mich und hat dieses Thema,
da auch spezifischer behandelt als als es mir damals klar war.
So, weil das zweitausendfünfzehn geschehen ist, weil zweitausendfünfzehn eine Änderung am G zehn Gesetz stattfand und vor allem diese Legitimationsgründe erweitert wurden.
Wurde damit das Fenster geöffnet, um die Befugnisse neu von Karlsruhe prüfen lassen zu können,
ja? Weil es ja eben neunzehnhundertneunundneunzig das letzte Mal, was dazu gab, Karlsruhe hat geurteilt, das steht ja erstmal.
Nun haben sich aber also,
Und dadurch, dass eben dem BND zweitausendfünfzehn die zusätzliche Kompetenz der strategischen Überwachung auch gegen Cybergefahren gegeben wurde, konnte man quasi wieder neu gegen das G zehn Gesetz eine Verfassungsbeschwerde,
ähm anstrengen. So, das hat nun getan,
Matthias Becker, Matthias Becker war auch äh Sachverständiger äh zum BND-Gesetz. Da bestellt von der äh Grünen Bundestagsfraktion.
Und ähm hat das sehr kritisch gesehen. Es war einer der Kritiker da, den haben wir auch
wenn ich mich recht entsinne im NSA, NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss gesehen und er war übrigens auch einer der Sendungsgäste, die leider für Lokboden Netzbetrieb zweihundert dann
keine Zeit hatten.
Genau, Professor für Informationsrecht an der Johannes Gutenberg Universität in Mainz.
Genau, kürzlich nach Mainz gewechselt, davor am KIT ähm,
Verfassungsrechtler und so weiter, ja? Ein guter Mann. So, der hat jetzt diese ähm diese,
diese Klageschrift formuliert, die viele Seiten umfasst und argumentiert.
Zehn Jahre später, nachdem quasi Anfang der Zweitausender ähm diskutiert wurde. Ähm wie.
Der BND Daten abhören darf, wird überhaupt erstmal dieses Ausmaß sichtbar, ja? Wir haben Internetknotenpunkte, wir haben diese ganzen Meterdaten, die da gesammelt werden. Wir haben das Ausmaß der Vollüberwachung, hat sich jetzt einfach mal,
signifikant geändert, ja? Äh Telekommunikation ist mittlerweile eine Basisinfrastruktur auf der unterschiedliche Dienste aufsetzen, wie vernetzte Autos oder Haustechnik. Sie ist damit viel bedeutsamer und viel verwundbarer als früher,
Und dann sagt er, damit könne eine anlasslose, strategische Überwachung ohne konkrete Verdachtsmomente eigentlich nicht mehr oder allenfalls unter deutlich höheren Anforderungen legitimiert werden. Das möchte er gerne äh möchten sie gerne in.
In Karlsruhe geklärt haben. Dann sagt er, wir haben eine kaum eingeschränkte Erfassung von Ausländern,
Und deswegen beteiligen sich dieses Mal zwei Kläger, die als Ausländer häufig miteinander oder mit deutschen Stellen kommunizieren,
Man will also
damit argumentativ bereits auf potentielle künftige Verfahren gegen die jüngste Reform der BND Befugnisse hinführen, die weder dem Ausspähen von Freunden etwa in EU-Ländern noch von Ausländern in Drittstaaten einrichten
Regeln vorschieben, ja? Und jetzt wird's interessant, dass dieser Aspekt argumentativ bereits auf potenzielle, künftige Verfahren.
Hinarbeiten. Ähm denn diese Klage, die da äh von Matthias Becker formuliert ist.
Dahinter stehen eigentlich zwei ähm Organisationen. Das ist einmal ähm Amnesty International.
Und einmal die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat sich schon vor über einem Jahr in Deutschland gegründet, tritt aber jetzt erstmals öffentlich auf und ähm,
da können wir mal,
Ein Blick drauf werfen, also die hat quasi sich schon länger ähm darauf vorbereitet, dass das jetzt hier passieren würde. Ähm,
Schauen wir uns mal das Team in der Gesellschaft. Nee, wir schauen uns erstmal die die Gründungsmitglieder an. Ähm.
Der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, da sind nämlich einige Namen hinter, die wir äh schon kennen,
Die ersten Mitglieder, also die Gründungsmitglieder der Gesellschaft Freiheitsrechte. Markus Beckerdal, bekannt als äh Chefredakteur von Netzpolitik Ork. Hm.
Ähm Doktor Stefan Brink, Jurist und ehemaliger wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter des Verfassungsgerichts im Dezernat von Professor Doktor Reinhard,
Geyer von der SPD. Doktor Boris Burg hat wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter der Humor-Universität zu Berlin und habilitant bei Professor,
Gerhard Werle. Doktor Nicolas Gazeas, Rechtsanwalt und Strafverteidiger in der Kanzlei,
Zambi Karkis und Partner in Köln und Lehrbeauftragte hatten dann an der Universität zu können. Jannik Hahn, Mitbegründer des Forums Netzpolitik der Berliner Berliner SPD und dessen Vorsitzender.
Kerstin Hillt, Journalistin vor allem bei der deutschen Welle.
Oha, jetzt kommen wieder bekanntere Namen. Andre Meister, Sozialwissenschaftler und Journalist bei Netzpolitik Org. Ähm,
Professor Tobias Singelstein, Juniorprofessor für Strafrecht und Strafprozessrecht an der freien Universität Berlin und,
Doktor John Philipp Zohn, Richter auf Probe am Sozialgericht in Berlin. Die sind also hingegangen und haben diese Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte äh gegründet. Haben da ein größeres Team aufgestellt,
Und deren Ziel ist es, strategisch zu klagen. Also ähm ach so, das Team sollte man hier jetzt auch nochmal kurz benennen. Das ist, das sind auch nochmal die wichtigen Namen. Doktor Olf Burmeier, bei uns schon öfter äh zu Gast gewesen.
Äh bekannt auch als Podcaster mit der Lage der Nation. Ähm.
Dann Professor Doktor Nora Markhardt, Mitglied des Vorstands der GF Juniorprofessorin für öffentliches Recht, Völkerrecht und Global Constitutionalism an der Universität Hamburg, Malte Spitz. Ähm.
Autor, Aktivist für Bürgerrechte, Datenschutzberater und Politiker, wir erinnern uns das Licht an das an das Licht, an das Buch, was macht ihr mit meinen Daten? Und Volker Tripp, den wir auch hier schon zu Gast hatten
und der Geschäftsführer des Vereins digitale Gesellschaft ist. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist, hier sind ein paar äh bekanntere Namen und vor allem eine ganze Menge Juristen.
Und die haben diesen Verein gegründet, um quasi strategisch sich mit Gesetzgebung,
und Verfassungsrecht auseinanderzusetzen und diese Klagen anzustrengen, um diese,
Überwachungsgesetzgebung, die immer wieder auch mit kleinen äh kleinen Teilen vorangeht, ähm wieder in ihre in ihren Zaun zu zwingen.
Ich denke, eine der Vorlagen für diese Bewegung. Man kann sich ja fragen so, oh Gott, jetzt haben wir schon so viele digitale Bewegungen äh im Netzpolitischen Bereich. Äh brauchen wir den jetzt noch eine? Äh ich denke, hier wird einfach ein ganz anderer Bereich ab,
als das jetzt die anderen Gruppen machen. Wir Netzpolitik Ork halt vor allem für,
Öffentlichkeit, teilweise Kampagnen äh äh sorgt oder auch äh Digitalcourage, einfach solche Kampagnen äh getriebenen Sachen sind, geht's hier ganz konkret,
Um Recht, es geht hier um Klagen und äh das auf allerhöchsten höchster Ebene Leute zusammenzufinden aus dem juristischen Bereich, die sich eben,
nicht sozusagen im eigentlichen Sinne ist jetzt erstmal so politisch aktivierend unterhalten, sondern die einfach ganz konkret sagen, wir sehen hier von Verstöße gegen Grundgesetz, andere Gesetzgebungen et cetera.
Und äh wir gehen das Ding mal quasi an der, an der Wurzel an und,
stellen das eben auf und äh insofern ist die GFF halt eine eine Ergänzung, die in dem Sinne gefehlt hat, vielleicht noch vergleichbar mit der ACU in äh die USA.
Spezifisch vergleich.
American Civillibertis Union, die ja im Prinzip genauso auch äh aufsteht zur Bürgerrechtsunion und die einfach im Wesentlichen einfach äh so im Sinne des Liberalismus da ähm,
agiert, weiß nicht, humanistische Union vielleicht.
Im Geiste auch noch äh vergleichbar, aber jetzt nicht in dem Maße.
Als primär, so als als klagende äh Institution unterwegs. Sondern ist ja auch sehr viel breiter aufgestellt.
Ich glaub wir haben vor zwei Jahren müsste das gewesen sein im,
Im Jahresrückblick des CC schon über den Chaosklageclub äh gescherzt
weil der Chaos-Computerclub da äh mehrere Klagen angestrengt hat oder mehrere Klang mit unterstützt hat, ähm was die Massenüberwachung anging. Und der Chaoscopterclub ist da einfach nicht,
Der richtige Verein für, ähm, die ganze Zeit rumzuklagen.
Sind keine Anwälte oder wir sind Hacker und wir wollen auch gerne weiterhacken, ja? Und ähm.
Was worum es hier geht ist klar das ist jetzt hier ein Klageclub. Spezifisch von der vom Selbstverständnis her, sagen sie wir ziehen mit unseren Partnern vor Gericht um Menschenrechte in Deutschland und Europa zu schützen,
Von besonderer Bedeutung für unseren Erfolg sind dabei die drei Säulen unserer Arbeit. Erstens, eine langfristige Strategie für Grund- und Menschenrechte,
Zweitens, die sorgsame Auswahl unserer Fälle im Lichte dieser Strategie, ne? Also.
Also nicht auf alles drei äh draufhauen, was bei dreini auf den Bäumen ist.
Um, sondern um um strategisch zu gucken, wo sind die Punkte, wo wir das Ganze, wo wir Sachen zum Fall bringen können, die möglichst viel Grund und und Menschenrechte wieder herstellen,
dann eben die richtigen Klägerinnen und Kläger, also die strategische Auswahl von Partnern. Das ist das klingt so ähm also so zynisch, auch wenn man da zum ersten Mal drüber spricht, wenn ich, also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel mit ähm.
Einigen Jahren mich mal über irgendwas mit einem Anwalt von der ACDU unterhalten habe. Ja? Da habe ich war ich in New York habe ich mit einem Anwalt der ECU gesprochen und der hat dann gesagt, so ich möchte,
der sitzt dann wirklich so an seinem Schreibtisch und sagt, pass auf, ich möchte dieses Gesetz da weghaben, das gefällt mir nicht.
Und ich muss jetzt, ich suche aber gerade noch den richtigen Kleke an
aber es echt geil ist, ne? Also wenn da so so drüber nachzudenken, da denkt man natürlich, das ist irgendwie äh was ist das denn, ne? Aber ähm in den USA ist die ACL Juda mit seit vielen Jahren ähm,
erfolgreich und die IFF ebenfalls und das ist das, was wir jetzt brauchen. Das ist das Einzige, was äh was äh du noch
was uns jetzt noch hilft, wenn wir irgendwie mit so einer großen Koalition eins nach dem anderen uns um die Ohren pflicht und es geht ja dann in Ländern weiter, ja? Es sind so viele Dinge, dass ich ja hier als jemand, der jede Woche die Sachen sogar nochmal gezwungen ist
zu zu ähm zusammenzufassen, den Überblick nicht mehr habe, wie zum Beispiel das sind irgendwie in Bayern jetzt schon der Verfassungsschutz, äh das Recht zum Zugriff auf die ähm.
Auf die Vorortszahlenspeicherungsdaten,
also dass irgendwie Daten zur Strafverfolgung gesammelt werden und einfach mal zack in einem Bundesland den Geheimdiensten äh zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Was ein Skandal sondergleichen ist. Da muss halt dann irgendwo einer sein, der sagt, alles klar, jetzt klagen wir dagegen
Und ähm das ist das, wo wir und das müssen die richtigen Leute sein, die Ahnung haben. Und ich denke mit hier ähm
einem Aufgebot an ähm dekorierten Juristen, die.
Ihr Handwerk verstehen und die wissen, wie man strategisch diese,
Gebäude, die da errichtet werden zu Fall bringt, das ist sicherlich äh etwas, was wir sehr gut gebrauchen können zur aktuellen Zeit und ähm.
Vor allem zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo jetzt im Prinzip auch noch das eine oder andere wirklich noch verhinderbar ist.
Genau. Also.
Mit großer Erleichterung äh beobachte ich, dass äh die die Gründung der GF, die nun mit unterschiedlichen Partnern gegen unterschiedliche ähm Gesetze.
Vor Gericht ziehen wird und da eben ne, sich auch die richtigen Leute ranholt, ne? Matthias Becker hier dann mit MSC da und zack drauf, ne? Und genau das, diese strategische Klagen ist etwas, was eben auch nur ähm solche Juristen wirklich können,
und dafür brauchen die Zeit und äh bei Juristen ist das ja so, die brauchen ja dann auch immer Geld, weil der.
Der Porsche, du hast keine Ahnung, was der schluckt, ne? Also es ist echt schlimm.
Sorry, der musste sein. Nein, das
da muss man natürlich auch sagen, das ist eine, das ist eine harte Arbeit. Man kann sich ja einfach mal anschauen, ähm was der Matthias Becker da formuliert hat und da kann man schon auch verstehen, dass der, dass dass das eine Arbeit ist
die eben jetzt auch nicht jemand einfach mal als Aktivist irgendwie so leisten kann. Da da wird nach Spenden gesucht und das ist wahrscheinlich nicht,
ähm nicht verkehrt, das äh zu unterstützen.
Ja, finde ich gut. Äh dass wir quasi jetzt auch um diese,
Perspektive und auch um diese spezifische Ausrichtung ähm der Gesamtmenge Lage da bereichert werden. Insofern danke auch schon mal an alle, die das jetzt vorangetrieben haben,
war jetzt schon das erste Mal habe ich vor einem Jahr davon gehört, dass das äh auf den Weg gebracht werden soll und jetzt sind sie ja auch,
nicht nur einfach so angetreten mit uns gibt's jetzt und jetzt fangen wir mal an zu gucken was wir tun, sondern die Öffentlichkeit wurde jetzt hier ganz konkret mit dem Einleiten der ersten Klage eröffnet, womit dann auch schon mal deutlich unterstrichen wird, wohin die Reise gehen soll,
Das wird auch nicht die letzte bleiben.
Nee, also hoffentlich nicht.
Ähm vorausgesetzt. Das Projekt kriegt natürlich auch die notwendige Finanzierung. Ähm auch da gibt's eine Spendenmöglichkeit, die ihr euch vielleicht mal anschauen sollte.
Die kommen natürlich mit den Erfolgen, ne? Also erstmal.
Erstmal erstmal uns.
Die haben ja ein bisschen die haben ja ein bisschen die haben ja ein bisschen die haben ja schon eine Anschubfinanzierung. Sagen wir's mal so.
Na gut, aber.
Also wir freuen uns, wir freuen uns, dass es das gibt und äh wünschen viel Erfolg, weil das ist wirklich die Klagerei, will ich mich jetzt nicht auch noch mit auseinandersetzen. Das ist aber enorm wichtig.
Kommen wir mal zu einer Klage. Da können wir direkt sehen wie klar den Klagen hilft, helfen würde, wer ist verboten?
Ähm die lange diskutierte.
Ein langdiskutiertes Thema war, dass wir ja im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss immer wieder auf die Tatsache zu sprechen kamen, dass die NSA dem BND,
mehr oder minder automatisch Selektoren gegeben hat, die dieser anwenden sollte bei seiner.
Überwachung. Also Suchmerkmale wie Telefonnummern, E-Mail oder IP-Adressen.
Und gesagt hat, hier Anti-Terror äh äh sucht da mal nach. Und der BND hat dann die Ergebnisse an die NSA geliefert. Einige Zeit ohne da wirklich drauf zu achten, was da genau ist und es stellte sich dann raus, dass im Fokus der USA,
Europäische Politiker und Firmen waren und der BND diese ausspioniert hat.
Und diese Daten an die NSA geliefert hat, was ein ein Skandal unermessbaren Ausmaßes ist,
das geht gar nicht, das geht echt gar nicht. So, ne? Und ähm,
Das war hier immer lange Debatte, denn die Frage war, was ist, es wurden am Ende zehntausende heikle,
Selektoren aussortiert. Als der BND irgendwann mal gemerkt hat, huch äh ups wir äh spielen hier gegen äh was weiß ich EADS und liefern das alles Freihaus, an die Amis.
Ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht gut. Es ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht gut. Und dann haben die Leute im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss gesagt, der zeig doch mal,
Verrat doch mal, was ihr da sucht, was waren denn so die Selektoren, die ihr aussortiert habt? Und dann war dieses gesamte ähm diese gesamte Geschichte mit dem Graulich, der dann da irgendwie nochmal ein paar Selektoren eingesehen hat, aber ähm
Das Kanzleramt hat klar gesagt, uns liegen die vor? Aber wir verweigern.
Wir als Bundesregierung verweigern dem NSN-Untersuchungsausschuss die Einsicht in diese Selektoren.
Und dann hat der NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss äh dagegen geklagt und hat gesagt, wir wollen das sehen, beziehungsweise es war natürlich die Oppositionsparteien des NSR-Untersuchungsausschusses, die dagegen geklagt haben. Und ähm,
Da wurde dann jetzt von Karlsruhe ein Urteil gesprochen in dieser Angelegenheit. Die Richter urteilten, ich zitiere einen Zeitungsartikel, ähm,
Das Geheimhaltungsinteresse der Regierung gegen die ja geklagt wurde? Überwiege,
In diesem besonderen Fall das Informationsinteresse des Untersuchungsausschusses.
Die Bundesregierung hatte sich überzeugt gezeigt, dass eine Herausgabe dieser Selektoren, die er von der NSA waren.
Ohne das Einverständnis der USA.
Die Funktionsfähigkeit der Nachrichtendienste und damit die Außen und sicherheitspolitische Handlungsfähigkeit Deutschland erheblich beeinträchtigen würde.
Das Argument kennen wir schon. Überraschend ist, dass es die die Richter in Karlsruhe überzeugt hat, was die, was die Bundesregierung im Prinzip sagt, ist, pass auf. Diese Sektoren, die wir hier eindeutig.
Illegal verwendet haben und zu denen wir Ergebnisse an die USA geliefert haben. Die können wir nicht öffentlich machen.
Weil dann werden die USA sauer und dann arbeiten die nicht mehr mit uns zusammen.
Ja, haben die uns nicht mehr lieb.
Weil dann sind wir ja kein vertrauenswürdiger Partner mehr, weil wenn man uns äh Selektoren unterschiebt, die gegen gegen unsere Befugnisse, gegen die Verfassung, äh gegen alles, was uns gut und lieb ist, äh verstoßen,
Und wir die zum Einsatz bringen, die USA nicht mehr sicher sein kann, dass das nicht irgendwann mal rauskommt. Und deswegen tun wir das nicht.
Und Karlsruhe sagt.
Dieses Geheimhaltungsinteresse und die Funktionsfähigkeit der Nachrichtendienste und ihrer Kooperation mit ihren internationalen Partnern überwiegt das Interesse des Untersuchungsausschusses, die Missetaten und Verstöße hier,
aufzuklären. Allerdings sagt das ähm.
Sagt, dass äh sagt das Bundesverfassungsgericht weiterhin so gesinngemäß ihr wisst ja, dass das der Fall war und es ist ausreichend, dass diese Tatsache,
Dokumentiert und spezifiziert ist. Ihr braucht für eure Aufklärungsarbeiten nun nicht die Selektoren im Einzelnen.
Es reicht, dass ihr sozusagen von dem Vorfall als solches.
Es reicht, dass er die Anzahl der Sektoren kennt. Es reicht, dass der graulich euch da ein bisschen was zu erzählt hat. Ihr braucht jetzt nicht auch noch Einsicht in was diese Selektoren spezifisch sind.
Ja gut, also was hier im Prinzip manifestieren ist.
Die Feststellung, dass Geheimnisse an sich zulässig sind.
Auch schon mal eine ganz interessante Information ist. Und dann könnt ihr ja auch äh durchaus äh so da vorsichtlich hin delerieren,
das das ist doch vielleicht unter Umständen auch nochmal auf einen Startsystem hinausläuft, was frei von Geheimnissen ist.
Wenn es welche gibt, muss es ja irgendwo eine Linie geben, ab wo sie zusätzlich sind und und wo sie nicht zulässig sind.
Auch was solche Untersuchungen betrifft. Ist ja sicherlich ja auch nochmal ein Sonderfall. Wir reden ja gar nicht mal von Geheimnissen im normalen Prozess, sondern sozusagen auch im Untersuchen von Vorfällen, die potentiell Rechtsverstöße äh,
wahren. Trotzdem darf selbst hier bei einem solchen Fall.
Das nur eingeschränkt gemacht werden. Ich meine, es gab ja, ne, diese äh Konstellation hier mit unserem Bücherleser im Keller.
So ein bisschen drauf äh schauen durfte und eine Betreuung der Geheimdienste, bisschen absurd.
Hier erleben wir wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen auch die Grenzen dessen, was auch über den über das Verfassungsgericht äh ermöglicht werden kann. Schwierig, damit umzugehen.
Also man muss.
Ganz klar hätte ich gerne äh dieses Ding,
diese Sektoren in der Öffentlichkeit gesehen, denn das wäre der Punkt gewesen, um dieses diesen Skandal auch überhaupt mal in seinem Ausmaß greifbar zu machen. Ne? Ähm die Argumentation des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes hier ist aber zumindest,
Wie sagt man so schön ähm bei der Bewertung von juristischer Argumentation vertretbar,
Mit anderen Worten, das Argument ist ein zulässiges.
Nicht unbedingt eins, was ich toll finde, aber der Punkt kann argumentativ vertreten werden.
Man hätte sich auch anders entscheiden können.
Man hätte sich auch anders entscheiden können, aber es ist die Argumentation und die Argumentation ist eben.
Es bringt eure eurer Aufklärung über die Vergehen und die Defizite. Kein nennenswerten.
Zu gewinnen mehr, wenn ihr jetzt diese Sedaktoren im Detail kennt.
Es reicht, zur Beurteilung des Sachverhaltes, dass es sie gab und ihr davon Kenntnis habt und dass es auch keiner mehr in Frage stellt. Das habt ihr ja aufgeklärt,
Ja? Ihr habt ja die Leute in eurem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss sitzen gehabt, die gesagt haben, folgendes ist geschehen, dann habe ich das geschehen, dann habe ich mich gewundert, da haben wir mit meinem Chef geredet, wie hieß denn der Chef? Ja, weiß ich nicht mehr
ne? Also diese dieses Theater, was da immer äh regelmäßig aufgeführt wird.
Das ist die Argumentation des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes. Natürlich hat man sich ganz andere Erwartungen äh ganz andere Ergebnisse da erhofft. Natürlich wäre das nochmal ein richtig schöner Knall gewesen, aber äh das Bundesverfassungsgericht war sich offenbar,
Ähm darüber im Klaren.
Und wollte diesen Knall ganz gerne vermeiden, weil es dem Knall gegenüber keinen sinnvolles.
Keinen sinnvollen Mehrgewinn gesehen hätte. Das müssen wir jetzt leider so zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Ja
Tun wir dann auch damit. Wir nehmen das zur Kenntnis. Wir nehmen das.
Wir nehmen das zur Kenntnis, wir merken uns das. Das merken wir uns.
Das haben wir uns jetzt gemerkt. Naja.
Kommen wir zu den ähm kürzeren Meldungen.
Äh auch so ein bisschen Boulevard. Ich muss leider ein bisschen Boulevard reinbringen. Geil. Also ähm.
Sanchez hat in der Botschaft Damenbesuch. Zwar von zwei unterschiedlichen Damen.
Wie hat er denn das organisiert ohne Internet? Ohne Tinder.
Du meinte Leute, schön, dass du irgendwie auf klassischen Wegen, die renn,
In Malibu am Strand rum und heißen Pebeler Anderson und bring Kuchen mit.
Zum zweiten Mal beim ersten Mal, beim ersten Mal hat Pamela Anderson irgendwie vegetarisches Essen mitgebracht, äh was dann oder vegane Kekse oder irgendwie sowas, was da jetzt zu Scherzen führt.
So und jetzt geht's erst.
Äh also ich wusste es ist einfach so skurril, dass ich das jetzt einfach nochmal äh also ich gebe, dass ich einfach nur wieder bitte bucht das unter ähm.
Hier ist der E. Ähm jetzt war sie zum zweiten Mal da, hat wieder eben, er hat andere Kekse mitgebracht und diese People-Magazine, die denen Leute fotografieren, haben
festgestellt, dass sie dann ja doch einen leichten Bauchansatz hätte
was sie dann zu der Spekulation angeregt hat, dass wenn man da ändern sie jetzt von Julian Assange schwanger ist und ihn deshalb immer besucht. Ich halte das für ähm,
für weit hergeholt, aber so witzig, dass ich das hier nicht äh loswerden wollte. Julian Assosh hatte aber äh hier loswerden wollen. Äh Junior Assoc hatte aber auch noch von einer zweiten jungen Dame besucht.
Das ist eine junge Dame, die er seit inzwischen mehr als äh mehreren Jahren immer zu sich eingeladen hat,
Er hat immer gesagt, komm doch bitte mal zu mir. Und das ist die äh schwedische Staatsanwältin Ingrid Isgren
Äh das ist die Staatsanwältin, die ähm den ähm Haftbefehl äh oder diese diese Vergewaltigungsvorwürfe, die,
vor mehr vor inzwischen sechs Jahren
gegen ihn in Schweden erhoben wurden verfolgt und ihn immer befragen wollte und dann haben sie gesagt, komm nach Schweden, da hat er gesagt, nein, ihr, ihr schickt mich dann zu den Amis und nach langem Hin und Her und das ging jetzt wieder über Monate ein ewiges hin und her.
War sie nun äh tatsächlich äh bei ihm in der eguadorianischen Botschaft und da gab es dann offenbar äh so irgendwie also ähm,
sie und eine Ermittlerin der schwedischen Polizei,
waren dann bei diesen Gesprächen in der Ecuadorianischen Botschaft nur anwesend, denn sie mussten ihren Fragenkatalog im Voraus einreichen.
Und diese Befragung fand dann statt äh durch einen ecuadorianischen Staatsanwalt. Ja.
Also der, ne, sie haben quasi ihre Fragen geschickt, dann durften sie sich da hinsetzen, da hat der ecuadorianische Staatsanwalt die Fragen gestellt. Da hat der Julian Assoc beantwortet, die beantwortet. Das ging dann wohl auch über mehrere Tage oder sowas. Ähm äh ja.
Ist jetzt alles gut.
Wie wir es äh bisher äh habe ich noch keine News darüber gehört. Ähm.
Was jetzt da das Ergebnis dieser Gespräche sein soll, ne? Also es könnte jetzt also ich glaube es war halt einfach, es war ja ein langes Kräftemessen einfach zwischen äh dieser Staatsanwältin, die diesen die einfach ganz normal.
Vorgeblich ganz normal diesen Mann da verhören möchte, gegen den es Vorwürfe gibt, die sie irgendwie klären will und ähm.
Dann eben Julian Assange, der gesagt hat, so ich rieche hier größeres. So und da gibt's äh es gibt sicherlich,
Gründe dafür, dass Julian Assanges sich da so geziert hat, nach Schweden zu reisen. Ähm! Ich hatte das ja vor längerer Zeit mal zitiert so, wenn ähm! Das
Natürlich eher die Gefahr hinter jeder Ecke wittert
dann gibt's aber wie gesagt diesen Streit, ob nun Schweden der bessere Auslieferer wäre oder Großbritannien und man wird jetzt sehen, auch dieses lange, diese lange Tragödie des Gezankes, wer jetzt, wann, wem, wo eine Frage stellt,
ähm,
Hat jetzt wenigstens mal nach Jahren eine neue, ein neues Kapitel und wir werden sehen, äh welche Rolle Permana Anderson da noch spielen wird. Ich fand das so schön, diese Meldungen dazu,
Ähm dann haben wir schon etwas länger äh ist es her, ähm.
Wurde eine Recherche des NDR-Magazines Panorama ähm veröffentlicht, die,
Eine Scheinfirma gegründet haben, ja? Seine Scheinfirma gegründet und sich dann bei Soldatenhändlern äh.
Surfdaten geben lassen. Und haben gesagt, hier äh wir wollen das da kaufen, was ihr habt so. Das machen und das möchten wir gerne haben.
Ähm gebt doch mal und ähm,
Dann haben sie diesen Datensatz bekommen und es sollten eigentlich quasi wird angepriesen als anonymisierte Daten zum Surfverlauf. Und dann haben sie diese Daten mal analysiert und dabei festgestellt.
Dass das halt einfach mal der gesamte Surfverlauf von Individuen ist, die sie aufgrund der Seiten, die sie besucht haben, ähm relativ einfach identifizieren konnten. Sie haben also mehrere,
prominente Vertreter, also Politiker äh ähm Journalisten und so weiter identifiziert anhand der Seiten, die sie besucht haben
Und dann haben sie sowas gemacht, sich mit denen hingesetzt und haben gesagt, guck mal hier, was ist das, ne? Und dann haben die gesagt, ja krasses, ne? Browserverlauf und so, oh mein Gott.
Dann gibt's irgendwelche Seiten, die ähm zum Beispiel wo quasi aus der URL, die du besuchst, hervorgeht.
Wer du bist, ne? Also was, ich stelle mir jetzt sowas vor wie eine Seite, wo es ein Login gibt und dann würde da jetzt quasi stehen so.
Slash Profil, Slash Adit, Slash Linuzifad. Und dadurch weißt du, okay ähm der Besucher ist
Linoziffer, weil er gerade sein eigenes Profil bearbeiten darf. Also ist er jetzt dieser eingeloggt. Also ist er das, ne? Dann sind sie ja zu diesen Leuten hingegangen, haben sie damit ähm
konfrontiert. Äh krasse Geschichte, dass diese Daten frei im Verkauf sind. Krass, welche
Tiefe sie haben und besonders krass, dass sie dann eben auch nämlich verschlüsselte Verbindungen betreffen. Wenn nämlich jetzt, also würdest du eine Seite per HTP aufrufen.
Dann könnte, was weiß ich jeder, der irgendwo männend Middle ist, diese Daten erlangt und an jemand anderen verkauft haben. In dem Moment, wo du sie über HTPS aufrufst, kann ein,
Überwacher mit normalen Mitteln, nur sehen, dass du dich dorthin verbunden hast, aber nicht genau.
Welche Inhalte, welchen voll URL du da aufgerufen hast. Ähm, bei diesen Daten war das nicht der Fall und dann haben sie sich auf die Suche gemacht.
Was denn quasi der Schuldige ist an dieser Stelle, der.
Seine Opfer da, verrät an diese Datenhändler. Und sie haben im,
leider nur ein Browser Plugin identifiziert, aber Anhaltspunkt dafür, dass es noch sehr viel sehr viele weitere Datenquellen gibt, die in diesen Pool reinfüttern und dieses äh Browser-Plug-in äh war ein Plug-in mit dem Namen Web of Trust.
Hat nichts mit PGP oder Web of Trust zu tun, sondern ist eine ein Browser Plugin, das dir, wenn du eine Seite besuchst, eine Ampel anzeigst, wie schlimm die Seite ist. Also so,
Lassen wir das, hat auf jeden Fall mehrere Nutzer, mehrere hunderttausender, Millionen Nutzer und wurde vor ein paar Jahren von einer Firma gekauft und diese Firma hat nichts anderes gemacht als dieses den den alten Divello Pa.
Ausbezahlt. Die Pflege dieses Plug-ins übernommen und dann da einen Code drin versteckt,
auch nicht einfach so einfach findbar da drin untergebracht, der eben regelmäßig nach Hause telefoniert und sagt hier übrigens mein Opfer hat folgende Seiten besucht.
So, nun, das Interessante ist, dass dieses Browser Plugin auch sonst nicht hätte funktionieren können,
ohne einen zentralen Server zu sagen, zumindest welche Domains man besucht. Denn es soll ja.
Je nachdem, welche Seite du besuchst, dir in der Ampel in rot, grün oder gelb anzeigen. Nun kann dieses Browser Plugin nicht
die gesamten Ampeln des gesamten Internets äh beinhalten, weil das sicher auch stetig ändert
vom Speicherbedarf her eben auch so die Größe eines normalen Browser Plugins überschreiten würde. Also hat dieses Plug-in ohnehin schon nach Hause gefunkt und war deshalb halt auch ein sehr guter Kandidat
für diese Firma umgekauft zu werden.
Wermutstropfen ist, dass dieses Plug-in eben das einzige ist und davon auszugehen ist, dass es noch viele weitere Datenquellen gibt, die äh offenbar den Browserverlauf, den Surfverlauf von den Leuten an solche,
Surfdatenhändler weiter verkaufen. Da werden wir uns noch ein bisschen mit auseinandersetzen müssen und ich denke, das ist ein interessantes Forschungsfeld.
Ja, Web of Trast, also die gibt's ja auch noch hier.
Das ist ja echt interessant, ne, dass sie sich sozusagen genau unter diesen,
ähm ausgerechnet genau an die Stelle äh äh reinholen und auf eine Art und Weise funktionieren, wo genau das sozusagen konterkariert wird. Mozilla hat's jetzt aus dem Programm genommen, aus dem Katalog genommen, ich weiß nicht, wie das mit den anderen aussieht
aber da wird sicherlich noch mehr gehen, die in diese Richtung gehen. Also macht euch auch klar,
Browser Plugins kriegen an einer sehr delikaten Stelle Zugriff und ähm,
haben da unterschiedliche Methoden, an welcher Ebene solche Plugins überhaupt äh eingreifen dürfen.
Und da lohnt sich auf jeden Fall ein zweiter Blick.
Ähm da gibt's äh diesen Talk von den haben wir glaube ich hier schon mal besprochen. Republiker Talk von Thorsten Schröder ähm und und Frank Rieger, die einmal sich um diese Werbenetzegeschichte äh,
Mit dieser Werbenetzgeschichte auseinandergesetzt haben, aber auch mit Browser, Plugins. Und das ist ähm,
ein großes Problem gerade, zumal hinter vorgehaltener Hand eh immer debattiert wird, dass diese ganzen Adblocker.
Ja auch ähm nach Monetarisierungsmöglichkeiten suchen.
Und mitunter äh quasi auch nur Tracker ersetzen, ja? So dass du also nicht, also ich weiß, ich möchte da jetzt keine spezifischen Adblocker benennen, die Untersuchungen halten an, ähm aber das ist eben quasi mehr oder weniger auch nur eine.
Marktstrategie ist zu sagen, ey pass auf, wir schalten die ganzen anderen Tracker aus und sammeln dafür selber Daten. Dafür nehmen wir quasi direkt jeder Kunde, den wir haben äh den nehmen wir allen anderen weg,
und ähm dadurch generieren wir für uns eine Möglichkeit, einen Fuß in diesen Markt zu bekommen. Ähm.
Und wie gesagt, das ist äh perfide, aber ein erfolgreiches Businessmodell muss perfide sein und deswegen ist es auch nicht anders äh denkbar.
Genau, wie auch erfolgreiche Podcasts.
Erfolgreiche Podcasts.
Müssen außer extrem perfide sein. Wir sind. Ja.
Wir sind perfide. Ähm,
Nee, da ist sogar da müssen wir noch ganz kurz darauf eingehen, dass äh WhatsApp tatsächlich die äh Datenweitergabe äh an Facebook irgendwie unterbrochen hat, bis das irgendwie mal hier geklärt ist. Das war auch so eine Kurzmeldung. Das ähm.
Weil die Datenschützer so laut geschrieben haben.
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ja, wahrscheinlich, weil die Nutzer so laut protestiert haben, das äh riss mich echt zu dem äh zu der,
na ja, da, das, also es riss mich zu der resignierten Einsicht hin. Der Unterschied zwischen Staat und Unternehmen ist, dass beim Unternehmen Protest echt noch was bewirken.
Das äh ja stimmt.
Ich hoffe, dass sich das ändert, aber ich äh mir fiel da nix äh.
Ja, der Unterschied ist, dass halt solche ähm dass die Beiträge, die man an an Unternehmen äh entrichtet halt in der Regel dann doch äh ähm auch schnell eingestellt werden können, so während das Steuer äh Aufkommen halt äh doch ziemlich regide durchgesetzt wird.
Ich will jetzt hier nicht völlig neoliberal werden und sagen, pass auf, wir.
Nee, das wollte ich damit auch nicht sagen.
Es gibt wir wollen hier Service Serviceregierung und dann wollen wir mal gucken wer bei welcher Regierung Kunde wird.
Ganz schlechte I.
Ganz schlechte Idee, aber okay, also wir werden auch sehen, das wird ja auch, das ist ja nur eine Unterbrechung und Unterbrechung aufgehoben, aufgehoben heißt der nicht aufgehoben.
Was aber wohl erstmal aufgehoben wurde, auch da direkt der Hinweis, das Urteil ist noch nicht rechtskräftig, aber das war ein schönes Urteil äh gegen die GMA. Was.
Ehemalige Mitglieder der Piratenpartei angestrengt haben, beziehungsweise als sie angefangen haben mit diesem Rechtsschreib waren sie auch noch mit der Privatenpartei. Und zwar ist das so. Wir hatten im April auch darüber berichtet, dass der Bundesgerichtshof entschieden hat.
Dass die VG Wort ihre eingenommenen Vergütungen für Urheberrechte ausschließlich den Urhebern auszahlen muss. Was sie nämlich gemacht hat, die VG Walt ist, dass sie vierzig Prozent der Urheberrechtseinnahmen, die sie ja hat.
Pauschal an die Verlage gegeben hat und da hat der der Bundesgerichtshof geurteilt, äh das ist rechtswidrig. Das äh.
Weil das sind ja nicht die Urheber.
Das sind nicht die Urheber, ihr schüttet bitte an die Urheber aus und für die Verlage ist damit ein spürbarer, finanzieller Verlust entstanden, aber sorry,
lasst die Urheber ja schon,
genug bluten, ne? Müsst ihr den ja jetzt nicht auch noch ihre Urheberrechtseinnahmen durch die VG Wart wegnehmen. Das hat also das BGH geurteilt.
Der BGH geurteilt. Und dann haben ähm die Piraten Brunokram und Stefan Ackermann ähm gesagt, dass die Kema das genauso wenig darf,
ne? Mit Rückenwind dieses BGH-Urteils. Und haben gesagt in einem längeren Rechtsstreit, der glaube ich schon vorher losging, haben gesagt ähm.
Dass die Gamer bis zu vierzig Prozent an Musikverlage,
äh abgibt und Komponist und Texter sich die restlichen sechzig Prozent teilen,
Das ist nicht gerecht. Wir haben damit beim Landgericht Berlin verloren, ja? Ähm.
Dann kam dieses Urteil äh BGH-Urteil zu VG Wort und dann haben sie vom Kammergericht Berlin nun äh gewonnen.
Sodass es gerade ein noch nicht rechtskräftiges Urteil des Kammergerichtes Berlin gibt, das sagt ähm was die GEMA da macht, da geht es gar nicht.
Jetzt sagt die, geh mal dazu, anders als die VG Wart beteiligt die Gamer ihre Musikverleger nicht pauschal
sondern nur dann, wenn Urheber und Verleger eine solche Beteiligung im Verlagsvertrag vereinbart haben. Mit anderen Worten, was hier eigentlich passiert,
ist so ein sittenwidriger Vertrag, den nämlich die Labels, die Musikverlage ihren ähm.
Ihren Musikanten vorlegen und sagen jo äh ne du hast sowieso schon mal hier den Knebel und schwer und haste nicht gesehen, Vertrag mit uns und von deinen Gamereinnahmen kriegen wir bitte auch nochmal so und so viel Prozent,
und das hat die GEMA dann nur als ähm
Erfüllungsgehilfe auch umgesetzt. Das ist also die Argumentation der GEMA. Wir sehen auch da wieder ein Stein, den man echt nicht umdrehen möchte, weil da wirklich nur fieses äh vorkommt, ähm hervorkommt
Aber immerhin ein noch nicht rechtskräftiges Urteil mit einem sehr schönen ähm,
Ergebnis, von dem man nun hoffen kann, dass es Bestand hat, denn äh wir wollen ja nun mal,
Die Urheber verküten und nicht die Verlage.
Mein Hinweis noch äh zur Terminalogie,
Kammergericht ist in Berlin quasi das Oberlandesgericht. Also vorher waren sie beim Landgericht und dann ist die nächsthöhere Instanz und dann die höchste Instanz quasi in Berlin ist halt dieses Kammergericht, heißt halt nur in Berlin so und.
Und dann haben wir eine gute und eine schlechte Nachricht.
Nur eine. Ja. Jeweils.
Ja. Eier. Die gute Nachricht.
Und die.
Die gute Nachricht ist, Günther Oettinger äh verlässt äh seinen Posten als Digitalkommissar. Das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Ist das jetzt rechtskräftig? Ja, wurde mir so angekündigt. Ja.
Ja, wurde mir so angekündigt. Die gute, also die das die gute, die schlechte Nachricht er wird jetzt EU-Haushaltsminister. Ähm der ist wahrscheinlich nicht so gut.
Für den Haushalt.
Für den Haushalt. Die Frage ist, was ist uns wichtiger? Haushalt oder Digitales?
Ja, also ehrlich gesagt, das Haushalts ähm Resort scheint mir dann doch eher allgemeiner gehalten zu sein,
Und vor allem, da hören unter Umständen mehr Leute zu, die merken, ob die jeweilige Person äh auch Kompetenz hat, während ich das Gefühl habe, im Digitalbereich äh war es dann sowieso immer allen viel zu,
kompliziert und da fiel es dann nicht auf, wenn dann irgendwie so ein Vollank irgendwie ganze Zeit Stuss redet. Also hier könnt ihr unter Umständen äh größere Probleme bekommen. Er sieht das vielleicht als Upgrade, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist auch ein bisschen so die Flucht nach vorn, nachdem er gemerkt hat, dass es hier,
dann doch alles irgendwie nicht so seine Abteilung ist.
Ja ja, also Öttinger, Öttingers Karriere ist ja davon äh gekennzeichnet, immer nach oben weg befördert zu werden.
Wenn er nicht mehr ertragbar ist.
Immer wenn er nicht mehr tragbar war, ne? So wir haben außerdem äh ich weiß nicht, wir hatten zuletzt, glaube ich, nur seine Rede beim ähm,
Bundesverband der Zeitungsverleger äh hier mal äh gewürdigt. Äh inzwischen sind da noch irgendwelche äh Reden aufgetaucht, in denen er äh Chinesen als äh Schlitzaugen bezeichnet
und ähm und sich irgendwie also in mehrfacher Weise
rassistisch äußert. Ähm, gestern wurde dann noch Thema, dass er ähm in irgend so einem von irgend so einem Milliardär im Privatchat mitgeflogen ist
aus Zeitgründen, was ein Verstoß gegen die Ethikrichtlinien äh der EU-Kommission ist, du kannst nicht einfach im Privatschnitt von irgendwelchen Milliardären.
Das haben doch die Ungarn vorgeschlagen. Die Heren über jeden Zweifel haben, ungarische Regierung.
Der Typische Regierung. Der Typ geht gar nicht.
Nee, der Typ geht überhaupt nicht, aber es ist schön, es ist trotzdem schön, dass er jetzt erstmal äh geht, zumindest aus unserem unmittelbaren äh Umfeld. Die große Frage ist natürlich, wer folgt äh ihm nach?
Das ist die große, das ist wer weiß, ne? Weil man jubelt so, ne.
Bestimmt kein Deutscher.
Ich ich kenne da die die Gemengelage gerade nicht. Wir mussten dieses Jahr durch so lange.
Wenn er, wenn er sozusagen jetzt Kommissar bleibt, dann kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das dann nochmal.
Ich kenne da diese Mengelage nicht, weil ähm wir durch den längeren Ausfall einer regulären Lokwoch-Netzwerksendung viel aufzubereiten hatten, wir werden dann die Personaldiskussionen äh gespannt verfolgen und sehen, was ist.
Womit wir beim nächsten Thema wären, ich hatte nämlich einen guten Vorschlag, äh wohin man Öttinger weg befördern könnte.
Präsident. Da ist das Schädigungspotential enorm gering,
dann hätte der da in seiner, hätte der da mit Privatchatten in seine Villa fliegen können von den Lobbyisten, hätte seine rassistischen Witze erzählen können, hätte ab und zu mal bei dem einen oder anderen
anderen Nazirichter am Grab ein vom vom Widerstand und dem Antifaschismus erzählen können, indem diese Nazi-Richter sich engagiert haben. Er wäre natürlich peinlich gewesen. Aber er wäre so ein bisschen weg von den Messern gewesen. Weißte, der hätte dann wieder mit,
Buttermesser gesessen und ey ich hätte mir seit die Neujahrsansprache.
Die hätte ich mir aber reingezogen leider wurde auch da wieder nicht auf meine Expertise äh Rücksicht genommen.
Und.
Wie so oft wurde da meine Expertise ignoriert, eine wieder besseren Wissens und besseren Rats äh scheint sich nun abzuzeichnen, dass wir einen neuen.
Bundespräsidenten mit Namen Frankfurter Steinmeier bekommen. Frank-Walter Steinmeier ist momentan Außenminister ähm.
Und Markus Reuter hat bei Netzpolitik Orgmal schön zusammengeschrieben, was das so für einer ist, den wir da bekommen, ja. Also er hat zweitausendzwei als Kanzleramtsminister den Datenaustausch äh zwischen BND und NSA abgesegnet.
Ähm daran konnte er sich dann aber nicht mehr erinnern, als er im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss dazu aussagen musste,
so einer ist das, ne? Er hat auch zweitausendvier als Kanzleramtsminister die Operation Eikonal gebilligt, wo der NSA einen Zugang zum Internetknoten Dezix gegeben wurde,
Da haben wir ja noch gerade laufende Klagen in diesem Bereich, wo der DC sich gerade gegen wehrt. Ähm.
Dann äh ist er bekannt ähm,
aus dem Fall Kurnatz, ja? Ähm ein Folteropfer, der äh also Murat Kunerts, der ähm.
Sich gegen der von Inguantanamo festgehalten wurde von den Amerikanern und im Jahr zweitausendzwei hat sich Steinmeier ähm gegen äh die Auslieferung dieses Menschen nach Deutschland engagiert, ja?
Das heißt, es gab ein Angebot der Bundesregierung, äh ein ein Angebot an die deutsche Bundesregierung von den Vereinigten Staaten, ihn,
freizulassen, den Deutschen, der in äh Guantalamo festgehalten wurde. Dann gab es dieses äh dieses schöne ähm Gutachten von.
Maaßen,
Der sagte, na ja, nee, äh für den müsste sich die deutsche Bundesregierung nicht einsetzen, weil der hat ja gegen seine Meldepflichten verstoßen ähm und weil er an aus Guantanamo nicht regelmäßig angerufen hat.
Frechheit.
Und deswegen deswegen können wir den jetzt in in Guantanamo verdoren lassen. Ja, dann gibt's noch weitere Fälle, die Markus Reuter hier zusammenfasst. Ähm.
Nämlich äh Mohammed Samar
wo er dieser Mensch wurde zweitausendeins in Marokko verhaftet und von der CSC CIA ein Gefängnis in Syrien verschleppt. Nachdem äh deutsche Behörden seine Daten weitergegeben
äh hatten und der wurde dann dort gefoltert. Auch hier äh reisten dann deutsche Geheimdienste und zwei BKA äh Mitarbeiter nach Damaskus
Um ihn zu befragen, während der da eben äh äh gefoltert wurde. Das Kanzleramt wusste Bescheid und da wieder Frank-Walter Steinmeier.
Dann hat er noch so seine Geschichte mit äh Hartz vier Leistungsschutzrecht und Kampfdrohnen ähm und jetzt eben,
kann er diese Geschichte weiterschreiben als unser designierter Bundespräsident. Auch da haben wir doch mal wieder ein Schmuckstück,
für die Demokratie.
Also ich hätte mir das schlimmere äh Optionen ausmalen können, um ehrlich zu sein.
Ich finde es trotzdem wichtig, solche äh Personen mal zu beäugen, ne? Also ich meine, jemand, der sehr zweifel in sehr zweifelhaftem Licht steht, ähm gerade im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss wird also jetzt zum Bundespräsidenten.
Das ist der beliebteste Politiker Deutschlands nach den Umfragen. Ne? Ist so.
Ja Donald Trump ist der beliebteste Politiker der USA nach den jüngsten Umfragen.
Ja, so ist das.
Ähm, ganz kurz kann ich das noch erwähnen. Ich war gestern in einer Radiosendung äh SWR eins Leute,
und habe da ein bisschen geplaudert. Das fand ich irgendwie äh fand ich ein ganz angenehme Sendung, die auch als Podcast erhältlich ist und die tatsächlich sehr viele äh interessante äh Gäste äh hat und hatte. Öttinger war auch mal da. Ähm,
Das kann man sich mal anhören, wenn wenn einen das interessiert.
Dann äh möchte ich darauf hinweisen, dass das Weihnachtsgeld natürlich dieses Jahr in die Netzpolitik geht. Äh Netzpolitik Ork hat einen Spendenaufruf und weist darauf hin, dass sie,
explodiere, also wirklich stark anwachsende Leserzahlen haben, aber nicht äh stark ein äh stark anwachsendes äh Spendenaufkommen. Ähm,
Und sie müssen ihre ihre Spendenvolumen um,
monatlich fünf bis zehntausend Euro erhöhen, wenn sie nicht bald gezwungen sein wollen, äh wieder Stellen abzubauen. Ähm das ist bitter
Aber wir haben ja äh wir haben ja alle noch ein paar Euro über und damit richten wir jetzt einen schönen Dauerauftrag ein. Die Spenden sind sogar absetzbar. Das äh kann man also äh nicht entschuldigen, da nicht hinzuspenden, kriegt man sogar noch so einen schönen Bescheid dann fürs Finanzamt
da muss dafür gesorgt werden, dass uns dieses Team weiter erhalten bleibt.
Natürlich nachdem ihr euch euer Loch Bundesbild T-Shirts gekauft habt.
Genau, ja, aber das ist ja eine einmalige Investition, ne? Also wichtig ist ja, steht da steht da Tropfen hüllt den Stein und so. Also bei Netzpolitik, Orgspenden dieses Jahr, bitte nicht vergessen.
Dann äh in der langen Reihe der Chaostreffs ähm erwähnen wir nun den Chaostreff Recklinghausen, äh der sich jeden Mittwoch um achtzehn Uhr trifft in der Hackerhütte,
Westscharweg eins null eins vier fünf sechs fünf neun Recklinghausen für Ortskundige, das ist die Zeche General Blumenthal. Der hat eine Homepage äh C drei RE DE
und ähm sagt ähm,
Das Schmankerl ist, wir haben eine ganze Zeche, wo wir rumhopsen können. Das ist echt krass, eine ganze Zeichen zu haben. Äh die hätte ich auch gerne und ich ich hoffe, dass ich bald die Gelegenheit habe, den,
Carsten Fricklinghausen zu besuchen und wünsche euch auch diese Gelegenheit. Damit werden wir am Ende der Sendung angelangt.
Ja, Zeit wird's.
Das haben wir jetzt aber echt am Ende so richtig runtergerasselt, ne?
Das ist das, was so Kurzmeldungen nennst.
Ja, irgendwie muss er hier mal kurz kurz ich kann ja nicht einfach nur, weil das zeige ich, wenn wir hier wenn du mal eben twitterst diese Woche keine Sendung. Das heißt äh nächste Woche doppelt so lange Sendung. Ja, aber ging die letzte Woche. Ging, ging nicht. Ging. Ginge gar nicht.
Ja, aber ging letzte Woche einfach mal ging überhaupt nicht. Ja. Das hätten wir äh ne.
So, ja okay und Schluss, ich muss jetzt auch weg, hier reicht's jetzt auch wieder, ne? Jetzt haben wir fast so lange Podcast, äh längere Podcasts als die zweihundert, ne.
Richtig. Ja ja, na gut, aber so ist das halt.
So, dann gilt der Dank, wie immer äh euch allen und diese Woche insbesondere dem Elmar und
allen, die mich durch kleinere Daueraufträge
in letzter Zeit unterstützt haben. Ich hatte das ja vor einiger Zeit schon mal angekündigt, dass das Konto auf dem diese Daueraufträge eingehen äh geschlossen werden würde. Ich hatte gehofft, dass sich das abwenden könnte. Es wurde aber geschlossen.
Und ähm damit werden eure Daueraufträge jetzt platzen und sich auflösen. Und deswegen danke ich euch an dieser Stelle
wenn ihr ähm das weiterführen möchtet, findet ihr auf meiner Seite Linus Neumann DE eine neue Kontonummer, die äh ich hoffentlich dann ähm behalten darf und wo das äh längere Zeit,
hoffentlich möglich sein wird.
Ja, ich räume mich jetzt hier mal nicht ein.
Habe ich dem Elmar gedankt, nee, ne?
Doch, hast du. Habe ich. Mehrfach.
Habe ich okay. Danke.
Oh Elmar.
Mir fällt da jetzt auch nicht mehr viel zu ein. Ähm schaut euch die Aufzeichnung an,
Von der letzten Sendung war, falls ihr sie nicht ohnehin schon im Podcast äh gehört habt, dann könnt ihr euch zumindest auch nochmal die Show von Methodisch Inkorrekt anschauen und ja, so oder so,
Wir sehen uns dann glaube ich, also viele von euch werden wir dann hoffentlich auf dem Kongress sehen,
Hoffentlich kriegt ihr auch alle Tickets und ähm genau, sprecht uns an, wenn ihr äh das sowieso schon mal vorhattet, so da sind wir ganz offen. Und.
Bis dahin.
Wenn wir, wenn wir jetzt schon Kongress sagen, dann äh heute ist Donnerstag, der siebzehnte elfte, der nächste Vorverkaufstermin ist am Samstag, den neunzehnten elften.
Ähm um fünfzehn Uhr Berliner Zeit und dann ist nochmal einer am Freitag, den fünfundzwanzigsten elften ebenfalls,
nee und dann um zehn Uhr morgens deutscher Zeit. Ähm da sind also nochmal und da solltet ihr ziemlich genau zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Ne? Fünf drücken bereit sein, um den Server wieder zum Absturz zu bringen.
Und äh für alle ein wunderschönes Einkaufserlebnis zu machen. Nein, da solltet ihr bereit sein, diese Kontingente, die ja verkauft werden, sind jeweils.
Wenige tausend und das ist beim letzten Mal innerhalb von so fünfzehn Minuten weg gewesen,
da solltet ihr euch den Wecker also relativ genau stellen.
In diesem Sinne wünschen wir euch viel Spaß, bis bald.
Ciao ciao.